almost all cross-testing to kill or
pacify scp-682 had failed miserably if
you haven't seen it go watch our video
on the legendary hard to kill reptile to
see just how powerful and terrifying
this creature is it faced the gate
Guardian an SCP with a flaming sword
hotter than the sun capable of tearing
your atoms to shreds and came out fine
in its Face-Off with a horrifying
scp-096 also known as the shy guy it
broke the Shy Guy's mind and reduced it
to gibbering despair even scps with
supposedly unlimited Powers simply
refused to engage the beast in combat
so when it was proposed that they test
682 with scp-999 a creature known among
Foundation staff as the Tickle Monster
the idea was considered laughable 682
had been burned suffocated cut up
incinerated and growled in the faces of
the Gods how could this so-called Tickle
Monster ever hope to survive an
encounter let alone win a fight some
even believe that this was the last we'd
see of scp-999 but what makes this story
truly remarkable is that that isn't how
this played out as you'll soon discover
scp-999 is an amazing and unique SCP in
and of itself
but its secret Origins and its
interactions with some other prominent
figures in the SCP Universe are what
make this humble slimy creature Beyond
extraordinary
prepare yourself for the heartwarming
Yes you heard that right the
heartwarming story of scp-999
several highly trained agents on 682
detail Place 999 into the immortal
lizard cell compared to the giant
reptilian sitting across from it 999
wasn't much to look at it's a large
orange amorphous blob of anomalous slime
weighing in at around 120 pounds scp-999
was nothing compared to the monstrosity
it was supposed to face while its weight
has in the past cause minor injuries to
some of its human handlers it has never
caused serious or long-lasting damage of
any kind to a living thing even its diet
consists only of candy and sweets with a
particular preference for M M's and Neko
Wafers it consumes these treats through
the cell membrane of its slimy body much
like an amoeba this extremely stretchy
membrane means the creature is highly
malleable including the ability to
stretch and flatten itself out to a mere
two centimeters thick at rest the
creature takes a dome-like shape around
2 meters wide and one meter in height
the closest things the creature has to
limbs are prehenso pseudopods those are
the arm-like projections normally seen
on single-celled organisms of which it
has at least three the more you hear
about this utterly harmless creature the
more that matching it up with the pure
embodiment of absolute hatred known as
scp-682 feels downright cruel in
absolute contrast to the misanthropic
attitudes of the reptile 999 loves
humans it has a playful dog-like
attitude much like an over-excited puppy
when approached 999 will react with
extreme joy and Slither towards the
nearest person in order to interact it
will leap onto them using two of its
three prehensile pseudopods to hug the
person while the third nuzzles the
person's face emitting high-pitched
cooing and gurgling noises throughout
the creature is apparently Pleasant in
every conceivable fashion as even its
odor has been reported to smell just
like the favorite scent of whoever is
smelling it examples have included
chocolate fresh laundry bacon roses and
Play-Doh it's almost impossible to
oversell just how beloved and benevolent
this strange creature is it's one of the
rare Sapient scps to earn the safe class
and it's allowed to roam freely around
its facility at all times apart from a
one-hour bedtime period between 8 and 9
pm in the rare instances that 999 has
caused harm to a worker at the facility
it immediately began to back away and
contract its body while whimpering in a
kind of dog-like apology
the closest the foundation has ever come
to having a real incident with a
creature was the time someone
accidentally feted a can of caffeinated
Cola causing it to become hyper for an
hour before becoming visibly queasy
you'll be relieved to know that it's
since made a full recovery
but what would happen when this
Whimsical creature is forced to go
toe-to-toe with the foundation's most
ill-tempered Monster the employees
observing the test watched in suspense
says 999 began to enthusiastically
Slither towards 682. it's no surprise
that after being tortured and almost
killed hundreds of times during testing
682 had grown jaded to the Cross test it
was regularly subjected to when it saw
this strange orange blob squelching
across the ground towards it its side
and groaned expecting the worst
what is that the creature asked of its
gelatinous guest
scp-999 began jumping up and down in
front of 682 like an excited puppy
creating a high-pitched squealing noise
just as it regarded all living things
682 thought the creature bouncing around
before it was disgusting and hardly
worth the effort to destroy was the
foundation even trying anymore with a
single vicious stomp 682 flattened the
friendly creature beneath one of its
feet observers were prepared to charge
in and liberate 999 from under 682's
claws but then something truly
unexpected happened the expression on
682's acid eaten face began to slowly
change it was beginning to smile
observers recorded a noise what they
thought could have been a chuckle as the
creature growled and said
what is this
I feel good
while The Observers looked on stunned at
what was happening 999 began to Slither
and crawl up from between 682's toes
reformed on its scaly leg and slithered
up along its side until it reached the
neck there it began to nuzzle like it
had never nuzzled before the results
spoke for themselves 682 was grinning
and chuckling repeating a phrase that
the foundation never would have imagined
coming from 682
feel so happy
happy
just when you thought scp-999 couldn't
possibly be more adorable you learn
about its greatest power bringing Joy
anyone and anything that comes into
contact with the creature even in
passing will experience a kind of mild
Euphoria as one's contact with the
creature is prolonged this overwhelming
sense of Joy increases and continues
long after you've separated from it
prolonged contact has completely cured
depression anxiety and PTSD along with a
number of other conditions including
rage and anti-social personality
disorders serial killers practically
become Saints after coming into
prolonged contact with 999 and in that
moment 682 was no exception and there
truly does not appear to be no
exceptions while causing happiness and
joy isn't a dangerous weapon when it
comes to scp-999 it is an extremely
powerful one and what's more scp-999
also appears to have an innate sense for
those who need its help most with a
particular affection for the hurt and
the unhappy the creature appears to be a
true altruist on a fundamental level
even risking its own safety to help
humans during dangerous containment
breaches in one dramatic instance 999
leaped into the air to block a bullet
from making contact with a member of
staff
as a result the creature is pretty much
universally loved by all members of
foundation staff it's the one SCP who
has never made trouble for anyone back
in scp-682's containment cell the Beast
was still smiling and laughing as 999
rubbed against its neck it was an event
so strange so unprecedented that The
Observers in attendance felt like they
were hallucinating for a few minutes the
monster kept dreamily repeating the word
happy but then suddenly the creature
began to enter a fit of uncontrollable
booming laughter it rolled onto its back
slamming its huge tail against the door
it had just Fallen victim to one of
999's favorite pastimes tickle fights
hence how it earned its Tickle Monster
nickname among staff
the tickle fight continued until 682
appeared to tire and fall asleep with a
smile still on its face after 15 minutes
of inactivity two d-class Personnel were
commanded to enter and retrieve scp-999
from the containment cell they did so
successfully but as soon as 999 was
removed 682 Rouse from its Lumber and
released a powerful psychic attack from
its entire body while laughing
maniacally it rendered all Personnel
within a certain distance incapacitated
as they collapsed in fits of laughter
allowing 682 to escape and go on a
violent Rampage
however in spite of this 999 showed no
fear and helped save some of the
bystanders as security officers subdued
and recaptured 682 and even after all of
this 999 showed no hard feelings towards
682 and indicated a desire to play again
it's a creature whose capacity for love
is so Limitless that it's practically
immune to fear which is all well and
good because the true enemy that 999 is
destined to face is infinitely more
powerful and terrifying than 682 could
ever hope to be what is this monster and
why should 999 have to face it someday
the answers to these questions all lie
in the true origins of scp-999 available
only to those with level 5 clearance and
Beyond it's a perfect example of how
something good can come from the darkest
places there would be no scp-999 without
scp-231-7
scp-231 was a collection of seven girls
all impregnated by horrific nightmares
in a ritual perform formed by a cult
known as the children of the Scarlet
King
these girls over the years that followed
gave birth to some of the most horrific
monsters imaginable
one of which According to some was
scp-682 these beings were manifested by
the Scarlet King a powerful
interdimensional nightmare God believed
to be behind a great deal of the
darkness and horror present within R and
many other dimensions Foundation
higher-ups have declared the Scarlet
King to be the greatest existing threat
to the Multiverse at large an scp-231
was his latest direct interaction with
our universe
the only surviving member of scp-231
scp-231-7 gave birth in secret but she
didn't give birth to a monster she gave
birth to scp-999 a being of pure
goodness that's right the nicest kindest
cudliest SCP of all is the direct
descendant of a being that's essentially
the dark God of all evil feel free to
take a moment to absorb that
the creature even healed the girl who
birthed it and allowed her to return to
normal life with her family once more
from its first moments scp-9999 was
making positive changes to the world
around it and according to ancient texts
from a Scarlet king-aligned culture
known as the DeVos
scp-9999 is still very much in its
infancy yet it already has the power to
pacify its monstrous siblings like the
aforementioned 682
it's believed According to some
prophecies and Foundation theories that
the power of scp-9999 will grow
exponentially as it matures
why does this matter well it's believed
by some that one day 999 will grow
powerful enough to overthrow not only
its own monstrous siblings but the
thought to be unstoppable Scarlet King
himself not through violence or hate but
through the pure force of happiness and
love burning out the darkness and
purifying the corrupted
while the humble scp-999 rarely
outshines its frightening competitors to
those truly in the know 999 is one of
the most powerful and valuable scps in
existence and may be the greatest asset
in the foundation's Arsenal for the war
against dangerous anomalous activity
after all what could strike more fear
into their hearts than the knowledge
that it might be love rather than
Firepower that finally dethrones the
Scarlet King
and for the knowledge that it may one
day save everything we know from a fate
so much worse than death with nothing
but affection for everyone and
everything it's worth offering thanks to
the little orange blob or at least an
extra pack of M M's before bedtime this
is possible the SCP site director wasn't
normally a calm or cheerful man but the
researcher had rarely seen him as angry
as he was right now his face turned a
deep beat red as he scanned the
documents on his desk before he asked
how months of valuable research on this
subject had suddenly gone blank the data
was completely gone the researcher
gulped nervously hoping a demotion
wasn't in his future and nodded how
could this be possible this was an
experienced researcher who should have
been taking all the necessary
precautions could the being they were
studying somehow have erased all these
documents himself that's just what the
researcher had been trying to find out
for months with hours and hours spent
trying to learn the extent of its
abilities well where are they the site
director asked I want everything you
have the researcher dropped a printout
of their research on the mysterious
subject's abilities on the director's
desk every relevant line read day data
lost the director let out a deep sigh he
wanted to hear everything the researcher
knew well everything he could remember
at least from the beginning the
researchers sat down and began to relay
everything he could about
scp-343 which some of the other
researchers had started to refer to by
the nickname God
scp-343 was first cited in Prague just
an unassuming older man wandering the
streets he seemed completely normal to
everyone who passed him by until he
decided he was tired of staying on the
ground an SCP agent stationed in the
area noticed the old man disappear from
the streets as if he was blinking out of
existence only to appear on a rooftop
nearby the local SCP teams were
marshaled and they had soon Tracked Down
what seemed to be a very powerful
specimen but scp-343 didn't seem
concerned he reacted calmly when
detained by the foundation and went with
him willingly he was detained in a
standard holding cell for interrogation
and examination but he seemed completely
at ease with his sudden confinement it
would soon become clear that this
ordinary old man was anything but
doctors back in nidlavu was brought in
to consult on the scp's classification
and that's when the first anomalies
began their assessments matched
initially but when it came time to
describe him physically things took a
strange turn older male seemingly
non-descript and with no unusual
physical features Caucasian and
appearance Dr nidlovu was confused by
what Dr Beck was describing in his
report this man was clearly black the
two doctors quarreled unable to square
their differing perceptions they decided
to bring in a third impartial view to
settle it their fellow researcher Dr Wan
she didn't take long before coming back
with her assessment older male seemingly
nondescript and with no unusual physical
features Asian in appearance possibly
Chinese whatever
scp-343 was
seem to be perceived by each staff
member as close in appearance to their
own race but that was only the start of
the anomalies surrounding the old man in
the holding cell Dr Beck started making
regular visits to the mysterious man and
in their first interview he asked the
old man who he was and how he came by
his abilities the old man had a simple
response I created the universe Dr Beck
stifled the laugh and decided to indulge
the old man's solution it was a
fascinating claim but could he prove it
without another word
scp-343 got up from his chair laughed
and turned around and walked through the
solid wall in the holding cell and
disappeared Dr Beck was about to hit the
panic button and Marshall the facility's
security to find him when the strange
man reappeared walking through the solid
wall the only thing that was different
he was holding a hamburger which he sat
down and enjoyed the facility quickly
went on lockdown and a full
investigation was done into how scp-343
breach containment but there was no
evidence of any security breach no
failures in containment and no evidence
of any other cells failing scp-343
hadn't broken through the security he
had just ignored it as if it wasn't
there at all when questioned about how
he had gone on his hamburger run he
simply repeated his belief that he was
God in between bites of his fast food
treat this would be far from the only
time strange things happened around
scp-343 SCP Containment cells are as
secure as they need to be but even the
least strict containment isn't known for
its Decor which is why Dr Beck was in
for a surprise the next time he paid
visit to scp-343 the Bare Bones cell now
looked like a comfortable home decorated
in Old English Fashions the scientists
assumed that scp-343 had been making
many more trips out of his cell to get
accessories to feel more at home but
that didn't explain all the changes to
the cell no one could explain how he had
install the Roaring fireplace in the
containment cell and everyone who
entered could swear this cell looked
many times bigger than any other cell in
the facility
scp-343 wasn't just breaking containment
he now seemed to be breaking the laws of
physics in the facility the rules of the
SCP Containment facility didn't seem to
be a concern to scp-343 but there was
one thing he didn't seem to want to do
Escape after every sudden exit he would
always return to his personal cell and
treat it as his home when interviewed by
staff members he was polite but vague
and everyone seemed to enjoy talking to
him it was decided to keep him on site
not attempt to increase his security but
restrict access and keep his room
guarded at all times to ensure only
researchers with level 3 access and
above were allowed to meet with him but
God works in mysterious ways minimal
Security Site 17 was one of the least
restrictive SCP Containment sites
posting anomalies that could be safely
contained and weren't likely to mount
violent escapes but as in every SCP
facility security was still taken
seriously and only those with proper
clearance could interact with the
subjects so why did scp-343 seem
impossible to guard while only level 3
clearance and above were allowed in the
guards assigned to protect the entrance
all seem to fall down on the job
security officer James who was supposed
to be keeping people out of scp-343's
cell had instead LED in multiple
visitors in addition to dropping in
several times himself when questioned on
why he had gone against orders and done
so he simply replied that 343 seemed
lonely and was so happy every time he
got company that it just seemed like the
right thing to do the security guard was
reassigned and new ones were brought in
but history repeated itself guards were
given stricter instructions to minimize
exposure but scp-343's presence always
seemed to influence them anyway his
containment cell was a revolve door with
staff members at the facility entering
regularly for friendly conversations Dr
Beck decided it was time to take matters
into his own hands he would meet with
scp-343-1-1 and express how dangerous
these security breaches were he would
try to convince the mysterious being
that he needed to stop influencing the
minds of the guards watching him or the
facility would have to look into new
measures to contain him Dr back entered
the containment cell and had a long
conversation with scp-343 and when he
emerged he had a big smile on his face
like he had just finished a reunion with
an old friend he gave the current guard
a friendly clap on the back and told him
not to worry so much about security
after all nothing bad was gonna happen
from letting people at the facility
visit scp-343 right he wasn't dangerous
in any way he also said that security
should bring him anything he requests so
he would feel less need to leave a cell
minimal Security Site 17 soon became a
model SCP facility with morale being the
highest of any site with most giving the
credit to the presence of scp-343
employees generally make daily visits to
his chamber and he seems to have an
encyclopedic knowledge of anything they
want to talk about including things he
should have no way of knowing guards no
longer quit their posts or break
protocol as their only real duty is to
keep track of who meets with scp-343 so
they can be interviewed and debriefed
after everyone's conversation is
different but they all report being in a
better mood after leaving than when they
came in no further information is
available on
scp-343's origins the full extent of his
powers or whether he is telling the
truth about being The God Who created
the universe the site director rubbed
his temples after hearing the
researcher's explanation so what you're
telling me is that we have an
uncontained highly powerful SCP that has
not only been breaking containment
whenever it wants but has managed to
destroy all the files regarding the
research on it the researcher's answer
was yes however the situation at site 17
seemed to be stable and they had come up
with a plan that should help to maximize
the positive effect
scp-343 has on the facility there were
even hypothesizing that staff from other
sites and even certain anomalies could
be pacified by 343's presence the site
director wasn't impressed though he
wanted the researcher to go back to the
drawing board and redo the research
after all if all the files were blank
how could they ever learn how to
properly contain it that's what the C
and SCP stood for after all containment
the researcher finally had to stand to
the director though and told them that
it wasn't a good idea that they had
already tried everything to contain
scp-343 but that it wasn't that he broke
containment it was as if he didn't even
acknowledge that an attempt had been
made to contain him he was omnipotent
aware of things he shouldn't and able to
do things that broke the laws of physics
without breaking a sweat there was no
evidence that this was God the creator
of the universe as he claimed to be but
there also wasn't any evidence yet to
conclusively prove he wasn't the
researcher's best guess was that this
was a powerful reality vendor whose
abilities knew no limits and that the
only reason he was staying in the
facility was because he wanted to and
doing anything to change that might
cause him to change his benevolent ways
the director's side as much as he hated
to admit it his researcher was making
good points he wanted to meet scp-343
personally but did he need to know
anything first well sir the researcher
replied he likes hamburgers but beyond
that he'll take care of the rest he's
right there where we left him in his
home waiting for his next guest flying
in a plane nowadays is about as safe as
catching a ride on a bus or commuting on
the subway of course that doesn't stop
people being afraid of flying to sum the
prospect of long-haul flights or feeling
the shutter of turbulence our reason to
avoid planes altogether and then every
year there are stories of downed flights
or those that go missing all adding fuel
to that aviophobia fire tank for example
the infamous Bermuda Triangle that
well-known region of the western part of
the North Atlantic Ocean what does that
have to do with the fear of flying well
famously a high number of aircraft are
believed to have mysteriously vanished
while flying over the Bermuda Triangle
their wreckage and passengers rarely
ever recovered stories like that are
enough to make anyone think twice about
setting foot in a plane again and then
there's
scp-787 as you may have already guessed
scp-787 is a plane specifically it is a
Boeing
747-200 with a wingspan of nearly 200
feet and capable of seating over 800
passengers the 747 200 is a part of the
famous Boeing 747 family of aircraft
these are quad engine commercial
airliners designed to be the safest ever
built the particular Boeing 747 200 that
has since become known by the foundation
as
scp-787 is slightly different from one
that might take you from your nearest
airport to your long-awaited vacation
though for one scp-787 has no known date
of manufacturer and no call sign both
which a standard Boeing aircraft would
be expected to have Additionally the
plane's entire exterior has been
repainted strangely even the windows
have been painted over and the paint was
still wet when scp-787 was first
discovered as for the inner workings all
of scp-787's mechanical components
including its turbines engines and
landing gear are in perfect working
order with no sides of any damage in
fact the SCP foundation's researchers
aren't even sure that scp-787 has
actually flown since its construction
the plane's Machinery looks so pretty
steam that they might be brand new with
no detectable signs of any previous use
however inside the main body of the
plane it seems to be a different story
anything not mechanical like the carpets
and seats have decayed over time perhaps
strangest of all is the cockpit both the
pilots and co-pilots chairs have been
replaced with two masses of computer
components arranged to take the shape of
two chairs so what you might be thinking
after all scp-787 is for all intents and
purposes just an ordinary plane not
enough to put you off flying right
nothing more than a Boeing with a few
little things off about it like some
missing seats and decaying upholstery
well there's that and then there's the
over 500 dead bodies on board in June
1987 this flight of the Dead was
discovered several kilometers outside of
the city of Bremerton in Washington
state the SCP Foundation moved in
securing the plane and swiftly getting
it into contain
now capped within a foundation hanger
the interior of scp-787 is monitored for
24 hours a day surveillance cameras and
microphones are located within the
cockpit passenger areas and even the
plane's baggage hold with recorded
footage and sound relayed back to the
foundation the idea of a plane filled
with cadavers is certainly unnerving and
more than a little creepy but why the
need for all the surveillance after all
the bodies on board are all dead right
surely they're not going anywhere well
let's talk about those bodies how would
you expect someone to die when they are
aboard a plane maybe they'd be thrown
around during a crash landing or perhaps
a sudden depressurization might cause
the passengers to suffocate due to lack
of oxygen under normal circumstances you
might be right but scp-787 is no
ordinary plane and the passengers on
board were not killed in ways you might
expect from any ordinary aircraft
accident referred to by research staff
as scp-7 187a specimens the cadavers
aboard this particular Boeing 747 200
all have dramatically different causes
of death some of the specimens show
signs of strangulation others seem to
have starved or drowned other bodies on
board have injuries like gunshot or stab
wounds while further corpses look to
have died as a result of blunt force
trauma a few have even been
exsanguinated that is completely drained
of all of their blood one commonality
among all the specimens on board scp-787
is that some form of Mutilation has
occurred 23 passengers had their tongues
removed a further 73 were Scout 230 had
Cyrillic letters carved into their left
hands and almost 500 of the passengers
had their fingertips removed let's recap
what we have so far first there's the
Boeing 747-200 found randomly sitting in
a field second it's filled with over 500
mutilated bodies and third each one
appears to have died from a cause you
would been typically expect from an
airline accident seems strange enough
but of course then there's the
apparitions and noises that manifest
inside
scp-787 which is why the foundation
keeps the plane under round-the-clock
surveillance so they can monitor any
anomalous activity taking place aboard
this flight of the Dead any attempts by
Foundation Personnel to enter the plane
during an anomalous occurrence have led
to individuals being physically ejected
from scp-787 causing severe organ damage
and internal bleeding for up to 72 hours
the anomalies that occur inside scp-787
range from the presence of loud noises
with no obvious source to the
manifestation of strange human-shaped
entities within the plane the first
anomalous occurrence recorded with an
scp-787 was in 1988 when the sound of a
loud pounding Was Heard against the
doors and windows of the plane's left
side two years later a male voice could
be heard from the onboard bathroom
repeating a singular phrase over and
over
philosophers always run from the
advanced thickening treatment in 1993
the plane's in-flight Entertainment
System seemed to be activated by itself
the overhead screen showed a bizarre
choice of in-flight movie colorless
pictures of a deceased man accompanied
by a female voice reading a Gynecology
book in Czech the same year the longest
lasting of the scp-787 anomalies took
place this time the plane's fastened
seat belt sign spent almost four hours
flickering while the first 15 seconds of
Jefferson airplane's White Rabbit played
on a loop over the onboard speakers it
wasn't until 1997 that the first of the
humanoid entities appeared aboard
scp-787 this figure was indistinct
lacking any discernible detail little
more than just a human-shaped standing
in the aisles observed by the
foundation's surveillance equipment the
figure was seen removing an emergency
oxygen supply and mask from seat h-43 it
stood perfectly still wearing the
passenger's breathing mask for over two
minutes before removing the mask and
disappearing from the view of the
cameras placed on board the figure did
not appear anywhere else inside the
plane another figure appeared four years
later in 2001 sitting in the massive
computer parts that made up the
co-pilot's chair this figure much like
its predecessor was indistinct in its
features for almost four minutes it sat
in the cockpit of the Boeing 747-200
just whimpering softly then it lurched
forward vomiting all over the console in
front of it before quickly disappearing
like the first figure SCP Personnel
collected a sample of the vomit The
Entity Left Behind after performing an
analysis of the sample research staff
found traces of nitrous oxide thorium
bird droppings and three human
fingernails at present the origin of
these humanoid figures is still unknown
could these entities be the souls of the
Dead passengers trying to offer insight
into what happened aboard this flight or
perhaps these indistinct human-shaped
creatures are the ones responsible for
the deaths of
scp-787's passengers the next anomaly
within scp-787 occurred in 2005. when a
female voice was recorded speaking
through the onboard speaker system the
voice said for your comfort and
enjoyment today pancakes will now be
served please do not leave your seat
pancakes will now be served please do
not leave your seat do not leave your
seat leave your seat please pancakes
will now be served yay pancakes exactly
what the relevance of Pancakes are to a
Plane full of bodies is still under
investigation by the SCP Foundation next
in 2007 the Boeing's overhead emergency
air masks fell from the ceiling only to
be snatched back upwards they continued
deploying and retracting for 14 minutes
while the plane was simultaneously
filled with the noise of Screams finally
the only other notable anomaly took
place a year later when the onboard
temperature with an scp-787 dropped 33
degrees from 20 to -13 Celsius in a
matter of seconds by the late 2000s the
foundation's researchers was having
little luck understanding the nature of
scp-787's anomalies instead they turned
their attention to identifying the
bodies of the deceased passengers on
board through the use of advanced
forensics and population databases these
researchers attempted to determine where
exactly these bodies had come from
researchers still haven't determined if
they all died on the plane or if someone
had exhumed them from graves before
placing them aboard for some unknown
reason in fact the answer was neither
and Foundation researchers discovered
something that no one had expected one
of the passengers was still alive to
clarify the body aboard scp-787 was
definitely still deceased but
researchers identified the cadaver as a
retired optometrist from Atlanta Georgia
who is still very much alive Foundation
agents found the man was simultaneously
alive and well in his Atlanta home but
also dead on board the Boeing 747-200
the subject was interviewed by agents
and had no prior knowledge of any
incident taking place in June 1987 when
scp-787 was first discovered even more
interestingly he claimed that he never
even set foot aboard an airplane which
his wife and son both confirmed to be
true so what does this mean how could
the same man have been alive in Georgia
and Dad aboard scp-787 perhaps the
answer can be found in a surprising
place the plane's toilet or to be more
specific the place where the things
flushed in the toilet go to examinations
of the airplane's waste storage tank
have revealed something very surprising
there was one more
scp-787-a specimen that had been
overlooked it is unknown just how he got
in there but researchers discovered the
body of an Indian man who looked to be
in his 30s the man who is wearing a
three-piece suit was found to be
carrying a number of puzzling items
including a surgical mask and gloves an
unloaded Beretta dt-10 shotgun several
cinnamon flavored mints a switchblade
knife an amulet that appears to depict
the Eye of Horus and a ticket stub for
the Return of the Jedi with the number
92 written on the back all of these
objects seem to be completely random and
the foundation has been unable to make
sense of what they were doing on the man
or why his body does not seem to show
the same state of decay as the rest of
those found on board there was one item
that may hold some answers though for
some reason this man also possessed a
copy of
scp-787's flight log the log consisted
of a series of coordinates which were
repeated
5478 times the coordinates point to a
seemingly random spot in the Pacific
Ocean several hundred miles away from
the infamous pitcarin Islands the island
that the famous mutineers of the HMS
bounties settled after taking over the
ship and leaving the captain adrift on
the ocean is this location the secret to
scp-787 while none of this is confirmed
nor denied by anyone at the SCP
Foundation One Theory surrounding the
area is that the location is another
Bermuda triangle-like location one that
contains some sort of temporal anomaly
that unwitting planes fly through only
to find themselves displaced in time of
course the problem with this theory is
that the man from Atlanta said he'd
never been aboard a plane before or at
least not yet it is entirely possible
that scp-787 is a plane that made a
flight at some point in the not too
distant future only to arrive back in
June 1987 by passing through a temporal
breach in the area near the pitcon
islands sure it might not explain what
happened to everyone on board but it
could at least explain how scp-787
arrived where and when it did every
plane is fitted with a device that
records flight data in the event of a
crash or other accident known to most as
as the plane's black box and researchers
were able to uncover
scp-787s inside a compartment under one
of the plane's seats the recorder was
found within a compartment filled with
toxic Asbestos and dried human blood
they hope that perhaps it would contain
some answers as to what exactly
scp-787 had come from and what had
happened to its passengers sadly not the
flight data recorder contained no
information besides one simple phrase to
be sorry while an inexplicable mystery
scp-787 is at least classified as a safe
Anomaly by the foundation seeing as
opposes no realistic threat or shows
signs of trying to break out of
containment the aircraft has only ever
caused harm to anyone trying to enter
during one of its sporadic anomalous
events but apart from that it sits
Gathering dust in a hangar just waiting
for someone to crack its secrets and who
knows maybe one day you'll be sitting on
a plane that's taking you to your South
Pacific vacation and the retired optomet
interest sitting next to you will remark
that you're passing over the pitkarin
islands and you'll discover for yourself
exactly what happened to
scp-787 in June of 1985. Mark Johnson
and his wife of 10 years Sophie were on
vacation in Myrtle Beach having a great
time while they relaxed on the sand
Sophie decided to take a picture of her
husband for their scrapbook so she
pulled out the Polaroid Super Color 645
that she'd bought specifically for the
trip she pressed the button waiting for
the picture to print pulled it out and
shook it which he expected to see was a
shot of Mark lying on his beach towel
what she got was a picture of her
husband in the arms of his secretary
they say that a picture speaks a
thousand words but this particular
camera takes pictures that are worth
even more than that when developed the
pictures taken with this normal looking
Polaroid camera revealed the innermost
desires of the person being photographed
welcome to story of
scp-978 the desire camera the main
reason the foundation keeps scp-978
Under Wraps is due to its use as an easy
form of blackmail all anyone with access
to the camera would have to do is snap a
few covert photos and they'd have
instant dirt on the world's most
powerful people to further stop this
camera from falling into the wrong hands
the containment guidelines strictly
forbid the use of the camera for
anything other than simple documentation
and all uses of it must be thoroughly
logged and checked so now that you know
what the camera does it's time to look
at what kinds of strange and mysterious
photos it's taken after all who doesn't
want a chance to gain insight into the
minds of the foundation's most famous
and dangerous inmates first to serve as
a control the team took a photo of a
blue office chair no change was recorded
proving that the camera didn't work on
non-anomalous inanimate objects some of
the earliest tests of the camera were
the photos that the research team took
of each other one by one the doctors and
their assistants were photographed in
neutral poses smiling as if for a
completely normal photo then they waited
while the photos developed like normal
Polaroids most of the research team had
minimal changes in their photos one was
shown slouched in his chair drinking
from a flask one was shown in her
civilian clothes getting ready to go
home from work one doctor was in the
exact same pose but with a different
colored tie on the last assistant
photographed however had their picture
come out wildly different than how they
were posed their desire revealed by the
camera was so shocking that it had to be
redacted and the assistant was placed on
temporary psychiatric leave following
this first successful test the doctor in
charge of the project ordered a second
round of tests to be conducted this time
on a series of d-class personnel a
picture of 1D class who was photographed
while eating in the cafeteria showed up
as scuba diving on vacation with his
wife and child he was allowed to keep
the picture afterwards another had a
similar result he was photographed in a
neutral pose like the members of the
research team had been and when the
picture developed the d-class was seen
holding a smiling baby whom he
identified as his one-year-old daughter
after that the results of the scp-978
test started to get a little well weird
a notoriously Twisted d-class known as
7294 was photographed in his cell and
when the Polaroid developed he was in
the same cell playing a cello made out
of a dismembered mannequin
d217-017 was a late-stage victim of
scp-217 a virus that turns organic
matter into metal you would assume that
her innermost desire would be to be
cured of her disease but when she was
photographed in her cell the resulting
Polaroid showed her completely made of
metal kneeling and praying at the base
of a black obelisk 1D class who had been
rendered comatose and was on life
support was photographed in their
hospital room their picture showed them
as only a limp deflated skin in their
photo the photograph of another d-class
who had become increasingly listless and
apathetic since their integration into
the d-class program resulted in a
picture that was exactly the same as
they appeared in reality except the
light in their cell was slightly dimmer
intrigued by these results the research
team wanted to see how the camera would
react to scp-148 a type of metal that
blocks the psychic properties of other
scps a helmet was made from the material
and placed on a d-class who was given an
adult magazine to read while his photo
was taken when the photo was developed
it was extremely blurry upon close
analysis the figure of the d-class
reading the magazine could still be made
out and around him the faint images of
several nude people could be seen the
research team wanted to see if the
results were the same when the camera
was used on animals photos of the lab
mice and rabbits showed them eating or
mating in their respective Polaroids a
zebra finch was shown escaping its cage
while a guard dog and its Handler were
shown playing fetch in the park when
cockroaches were photographed there was
no difference visible between the
picture and reality but the most
exciting test results came when the
camera was tested on other scps for a
few of the scps tested there was no
visible difference between the picture
and reality this was the case for
SCP-173 the sculpture
scp-343 nicknamed God
scp-014 an immortal man who is over time
being turned into concrete and
scp-063 the world's best toothbrush when
scp-035 better known as the possessive
mask was photographed in its class case
the picture showed an unidentified
individual wearing the mask sitting on a
throne and surrounded by three masked
corpses the team took a picture of
scp-043 a haunted copy of The White
Album that was being interrogated while
on a turntable in the picture the album
was being returned to its sleeve they
then photographed scp-049 the plague
doctor standing in his cell in the
picture the plague doctor is hugging an
unidentified small child and surrounded
by instances of
scp-049-2 when they took a picture of
scp-050 a mischievous statue of a monkey
reading a book the result was
predictably playful given that scp's
history of pulling pranks the photo that
came out of the camera showed the camera
itself with another picture of itself
coming out of the developing slot
microscopic analysis revealed that this
recursive photography kept going until
the cameras in the pictures of the other
cameras were too small to see the team
next photographed scp-053 the young girl
and the photo was taken as the young
girl was drawing with crayons in her
cell in the picture she was riding
through a sunny field on the back of her
friend
scp-682
scp-053 and scp-682 were even wearing
matching bows dresses and pink nail
polish when they took a picture of
scp-096 the shy guy though the picture
showed
scp-096's cell with nothing in it
scp-085 the living 2D sketch known as
Cassie was photographed tinkering with a
drawn car in the developed photo Cassie
was engaged in the same activity but
both she and the car were now
three-dimensional the team took a photo
of scp-106 the old man emerging from a
wall within his cell when the photo
developed it showed the old man roaming
a wheat field near an old farmhouse from
the porch of The Farmhouse an older
woman is greeting as cp106 with open
arms they also took a photo of scp-168 a
sentient calculator sitting on a table
in its containment cell in the pig sure
a teenage boy is seen doing complex math
homework using the calculator next to
him on the table are thick textbooks
with titles like complicated math
difficult math and math you need your
calculator for the photo of scp-261 a
vending machine that dispenses snack
products from alternate universes showed
the SCP in its usual hallway almost
completely buried in coins
scp-507 an otherwise normal man who
unwillingly teleports between Dimensions
was photographed while eating in the
cafeteria The Devout picture showed him
dressed as a foundation researcher
talking to other researchers when
scp-682 was photographed floating in its
containment tank the resulting picture
showed the SCP surrounded by the corpses
of all of the foundation staff and
mauling the person who had taken the
photo a researchers note accompanying
this photo reads well that was
predictable yes yes it was just for the
fun of it the team also tested the
camera's effects on a few other
Foundation Personnel they took a photo
of Dr bright while he was arguing with
Dr klaff the picture that came out
showed a tombstone engraved with the
words Jack Bright resting at last the
team also took a photo of Dr clef as he
stormed out in a hop following the
argument given that klaf's face cannot
be photographed they were curious as to
what the results would be the picture
showed little difference compared to
reality save for the fact that cleft's
head was replaced by an image of a hand
making a rude gesture upon closer
examination of the photo the team also
realized that there was a young girl in
the background who strangely had cloven
Hooves instead of feet a young scp-166
perhaps the team then took a photo of Dr
Fisher holding his pet hamster contrary
to expectations the picture revealed not
Dr Fisher's desires but the hamsters
showing the hamster sleeping peacefully
in its cage with Dr Fisher are nowhere
to be seen as you can see from these
test logs the effects of the camera are
well inconsistent with some photos
showing very immediate simple whims and
others showing the subject's deepest and
most secret desires while the
researchers working with scp-978 seem
like they had a lot of fun getting to
peek into the minds of all their
co-workers and test subjects there's no
telling what kind of pandemonium could
be Unleashed if someone on the outside
ever got a chance to use it thankfully
the camera which has been classified as
safe for obvious reasons is kept
securely in security Locker hj-12 at
site 17 which means none of us have to
worry about our own pictures taken by
the desire camera leaking out but if
someone did get the camera out and took
your picture what do you think they'd
see meet Trevor Hawthorne now known as
d-4651 on the outside he was an armed
robber who murdered two people during a
convenience store shootout Texas but now
since being condemned to death he's been
picked up for d-class testing by the SCP
Foundation now also meet Junior
researcher Dr Julia Reed an aspiring
Foundation scientist with an undiagnosed
heart condition the kind of heart
condition that doesn't mix well with a
high pressure job at the SCP Foundation
these two woke up on the morning of
December 6 2011 completely unaware of
the fact that they were only hours away
from causing one of the most devastating
containment breaches site 19 had seen in
years many people died that day but
thankfully for everyone else
scp-131 were there to save the day when
you think of a hero you probably don't
picture a pair of little cyborgs with
one eye and the intelligence of a
household cat but this is the tale of
how two of the most unassuming anomalies
at site 19 managed to save thousands of
people from two of the site's most
dangerous inmates oh open your eyes and
keep them open if you so much as blank
it's all over for you how long can you
hold it difficult right now imagine
you're having a staring contest with an
entity that can kill you if you dare to
Blink for even a fraction of a second or
even worse a creature that could
potentially kill hundreds or even
thousands of people if your attention
drifts from it for any amount of time
try keeping your eyes open with that
kind of crushing pressure we're talking
about two of the most deadly Euclid and
ketter class anomalies out there
SCP-173 the killer sculpture a violent
Euclid class entity that is incapable of
moving while being looked at if ever
it's unobserved it'll snap the neck of
anyone nearby
scp-689 known as hunter in the dark is
an equally dangerous and even more
attention demanding statue these two
entities are Beyond dangerous even
scp-682 is terrified of the killer
sculpture and researchers have been
considering the use of 689 to
potentially eliminate the hard to
destroy reptile for quite some time
their greatest concern though is whether
the 30 centimeter tall statue would
cause too much collateral damage to
Foundation Personnel in the process
Trevor Hawthorne was part of the
three-man d-class detail meant to clean
out
scp-173's containment chamber at regular
intervals while on cleaning Duty 2D
classes can keep staring at the
sculpture while the other tidies of the
cell alternating turns to Blink but that
morning Trevor had woken up in his
containment cell with a killer migraine
and soon that migraine would be killing
far more than just him the containment
procedures in 689 cell were also a
three-person job 689 is a small green
soapstone statue of a skeletal being
sitting on a throne believed to be some
form of Underworld death deity
discovered by German archaeologists in
India this is a work of religious art
that demands your attention or you and
anyone else who's ever seen this cutter
class nightmare will suffer a horrifying
fate anyone who's ever seen the statue
is infected by its anomalous effects it
must be observed constantly or someone
who's seen it in the past will suddenly
drop dead of a severe health issue like
a stroke or multiple rupturing organs
like the god of death the statue
represents it appears on top of the dead
body of whoever it just killed if not
continually paid attention to it'll keep
hopping from person to person until it's
killed everyone who's ever looked at it
its teleporting abilities and the fact
that it poses a threat to so many make
this a truly formidable foe it's kept in
a constantly lit cell and is observed by
two members of d-class personnel at all
times but a crucial third party in the
containment of scp-689 is a member of
personnel at level 2 or above they
remain in a control room wearing a
special visor to prevent them from ever
seeing 689 and becoming infected
themselves if the containment fails it's
their job to throw the kill switch on
The d-class Observers to prevent them
from becoming vectors for infection
today this job fell on Dr Julia Reed she
was linked to the two observers via an
audio feed allowing her to remain in
constant contact with them and she had
her finger on the activation key for a
pair of explosive collars that were
around the d-classes next little did
they know Dr Reed's heart was its own
time bomb now you know what we're up
against a snap happy sculpture and a
teleporting death statue with a Hit List
containing everyone who's ever glanced
at it what can scp-131 bring to the
table the two small cycloptic anomalies
have only one remarkable ability they
never blink that and a soft spot for
humans these safe class scps pose no
threat to their handlers and can even
form attachments to researchers and
other staff who show affection towards
them of course forming these bonds is
discouraged by site 19's director
because it can be distracting but that
doesn't mean it doesn't happen the two
iPods known as
scp-131a and
scp-131b are identical in appearance
except for their colors a is a burnt
orange and B is a mustard yellow the two
of them appear to communicate with one
another via high-pitched squeaking
noises and also seem to have an innate
ability to detect danger occurring in
the vicinity as well as danger occurring
near individuals they've bonded with
because of their inability to cause harm
and they're generally affectionate
demeanor the iPods are allowed to roam
around site 19. provided they keep out
of the way of researchers and stay out
of restricted areas they seem to pretty
much stick to the rules though check-ins
On A and B are required every hour just
to be safe as the iPods were moving
freely around the facility Trevor and
another d class maintained a visual on
the sculpture in its containment chamber
while a third man swept up the mixture
of blood and excrements staining the
concrete floors things were going fine
until Trevor's migraine got the better
of him a sudden flash of intense pain
shot through his head and in a moment of
weakness he made a terrible mistake with
an audible groan of pain Trevor closed
his eyes and forced his fingers to his
temples the groan had taken his fellow
Observer off guard and the Man's eyes
flitted over to him for a fraction of a
second but a fraction of a second is all
the sculpture needs in an instant Trevor
and his fellow Watcher had their necks
snapped and the third d-class was
murdered before he even had a chance to
turn around containment protocol
dictates that the door is to be sealed
behind the cleaning crew while they're
working with 173 but this time perhaps
due to complacency the guards had
neglected to reinforce the door they got
their heads Twisted 180 degrees for
their trouble
SCP-173 3 was loose mobile task forces
were dispatched to Aid in the
recontainment effort as 173 began
wrecking Havoc around the facility but
things were about to get even worse it
seemed like business as usual over at
the containment cell of scp-689 two
d-classes observed while Dr Reed
dictated to them over an earpiece from
our control center however what Dr Reed
thought were just minor chest pains were
actually the onset of heart failure when
the 2D classes heard their supervisor
experiencing a fatal heart attack on the
other end of the line they began to
panic this meant their attention wasn't
entirely on scp-689 and they were
further distracted by the chaos SCP-173
was causing elsewhere in the facility
murdering researchers guards and
maintenance workers alike which led to
power outages the lights in 689's
containment cells shut down guards were
dispatched to execute The Observers as
is protocol for 689 containment breaches
but the fact that resources were already
stretched thin by the 173 breach caused
a fatal error in judgment from a guard
posted nearby in a panic he opened the
door to find one d-class dead with the
statue perched on his body and the other
one running straight for him in blind
fear the two collided and tumbled out
into the hall both were now infected by
689's anomalous attention and both were
now doomed moments later the two of them
were dead the statue perched on their
bodies accidentally catching the eye of
several researchers and guards running
to deal with the 173 situation for these
two deadly anomalies it was becoming an
all you can kill Buffet the staff of
site 19 were now dealing with one
anomaly that needed to be looked at
constantly and another that if you even
glance at it you are effectively
infected with a fatal disease the iPods
sensing an imminent danger nearby
immediately sprung into action it would
be up to these cute harmless anomalies
to save the terrified staff during this
chaotic double Containment Breach in a
nearby hallway a fleeing Foundation
researcher heard the crunches of her
colleagues necks breaking behind her 173
was getting closer this thing couldn't
be outrun she turned and saw the statue
standing there just 10 feet away from
her a dead researcher laying on the
ground in front of it she was locked in
a deadly staring contest with the
sculpture how long she could survive was
now dependent on how long she could keep
her eyes open and it was getting harder
by the second she could feel her eyes
drying they burned under the ceiling
lights 173 just waited this wasn't a
contest she could win in a final moment
of Terror the researcher was forced to
finally close her eyes and she waited
for the crunch but it never came instead
she heard familiar high-pitched
squeaking noises she opened her eyes
crying tears of relief as she saw
scp-131 a sitting behind 173 watching it
with its constant unblinking gaze the
killer sculpture was paralyzed by a
cheerful little safe class anomaly
across the facility a similar situation
had unfolded with scp-689 the Statue of
death had claimed many lives but
scp-131b had swooped in and Frozen the
statue in place with its never-ending
gaze soon after a mobile task force with
vision blocking visors used Advanced
echolocation technology to collect
scp-689 and return it to its containment
cell everyone who'd seen the anomaly was
as standard protocol dictates gathered
up for later termination meanwhile a
mobile task force returned the paralyzed
173 back to its containment cell with a
forklift no Containment Breach is ever a
picnic containment breaches with
multiple dangerous anomalies are even
less so but the heroic role that scp-131
played in bringing things back under
under control was indispensable after
all it's not just raw power that counts
when it comes to anomalies the only
anomalous power 131 needed to save the
entire site was its ability to keep
looking when nobody else could they're
so effective in this role that they've
been seriously considered for permanent
roles as wardens for scps like 173 and
689 and in our opinion they're more than
qualified think back to your childhood
and ask yourself what was the most pain
you've ever felt while growing up as we
develop our understanding of pain
evolves according to our different
experiences the older we get the
injuries we suffered as children like a
scraped knee or a bee sting rarely cause
us the same level of distress as they
used to of course when you are young and
unfamiliar with sensations of pain what
you really need in that moment straight
after you've fallen off your bike or
tripped playing soccer is someone to
pick you back up and give your Source
spot a kiss perhaps you even need a bowl
of warm soup to comfort you luckily for
you
scp-348 is exactly that while many of
the anomalies held in containment by the
SCP Foundation have earned the Euclid or
inFAMOUS ketter class designations
scp-348 is one of the few considered to
be safe both in the sense it poses no
containment risk and in that it wouldn't
hurt a fly it is neither an ancient
Eldritch Abomination From Another
Dimension spreading its influence in our
world through memetic stimuli nor is it
a recording of a basketball game in
which all the players and Spectators are
trapped inside it isn't an
indestructible limb generating reptile
or a towering winged being wielding a
flaming sword and guarding the entrance
to the Garden of Eden to put it simply
scp-348 is a bowl a white ceramic Bowl
the kind you would find almost anywhere
in the world it may even look
indistinguishable from the one in your
kitchen cabinet of course scp-348 is
hardly as ordinary as it outwardly
appears to be and it certainly isn't the
only inanimate object that the
foundation keeps safely stored away the
key thing that differentiates scp-348
from most other anomalies is how
genuinely harmless it is its anomalous
properties do not cause injury to any
individual that interacts with it nor
does this bowl have any adverse effects
on the world around it
scp-348 cannot bend or reshape reality
it does not cause the person eating from
it to have premonitions of their own
death and using it certainly does not
manifest a contract making entity at the
opposite side of the table so what makes
this bowl in any way anomalous what
about it categorizes it as an SCP and
not just a harmless piece of fine
Crockery well why don't we start with
how scp-348 was first discovered some
time ago the SCP Foundation was made
aware of rumors surrounding the child
living in an unknown part of the world
according to the intelligence gathered
by the foundation this child seemed to
possess some sort of healing ability or
at least this is what rumors suggested
upon further investigation the source of
these so-called remarkable recovery
abilities wasn't the child but appeared
to come from a small ceramic pole which
we now know as scp-348 this is not to
say that the bull has any inherently
Supernatural healing properties and it
doesn't impart any regenerative power to
those that eat from it either it does
heal in a certain sense but not in the
way you're probably imagining when the
SCP Foundation recovered scp-348 there
were no markings on it indicating where
the bowl came from or who it was
manufactured by the only visually
distinct details worthy of note were
flowery patterns that appeared to be
hand-painted around both the inside and
outside of scp-348 the ceramic surface
also bore the Chinese letters shangshini
which translates to the phrase thinking
of you the child that first discovered
had found the ceramic Bowl in the Attic
of their home the child's parents were
both full-time workers and seemed to be
somewhat neglectful of their child
although they refused to comment on this
but according to the findings of the SCP
Foundation the child had come to rely on
scp-348 deciding to further investigate
the anomalous properties of scp-348 the
foundation began testing it given that
the child who first discovered the bull
had relied upon it tests involved
Foundation researchers presenting
certain children to scp-348 and
observing the results so was this bowl
haunted perhaps harboring some malicious
Spirit or entity that sought to corrupt
these children maybe even healing them
in order to somehow use them as a vessel
to break into our world no and while may
have not healed in any overt or expected
way it did heal in at least a
metaphorical sense if presented with an
injured child supporting any form of
minor ailments such as a cut or our
running nose
scp-348 fills with warm soup and yes
that's right we said soup what kind you
may ask well that seems to vary
sometimes it is tomato soup other times
it might be chicken noodle soup while
the ingredients used in the soups are
often different there are notable
consistencies to our scp-348 heals if
anyone between the ages of 4 years old
and 18 years old sits down in front of
the blue flowered Bowl then scp-348 will
fill with soup numerous young test
subjects brought in by the foundation to
eat from this particular bowl of soup
have reported that they enjoyed their
meal usually finishing the entire Bowl
when permitted to by research staff many
of the injured children that were tested
have stated that the soup they eat from
scp-348 reminds them of their parents
cooking these children have expressed
contentment and feelings of comfort
after acquiring their various cuts and
bruises some even claim that even though
they were in a room all alone they did
didn't feel lonely when they were eating
the soup and all the anomalous
properties don't end after a child
finishes the soup usually although not
always the bowl will leave the child a
message often some brief words of
reassurance or Comfort these messages
materialize on the inside rim of the
bowl and seem to be specifically
tailored to the subject that has just
eaten the words will not only be written
in the child's first language but are
often linked to the child's home life or
relationship with their parents messages
that appear on scp-348 usually fade over
time normally disappearing after a few
hours or when the bowl refills with more
soup one test of scp-348 saw a little
girl age 8 and suffering from a sore
throat brought before the bowl according
to a background screening made by
research Personnel the girl lived with
her biological parents and apparently
had a good relationship with both her
mother and her father when scp-348
filled with super her the girl took
almost half an hour to finish eating and
afterwards reported that she felt her
sore throat get better as she ate by the
end of the meal this test subject
remarked that she felt completely normal
in this instance no message appeared
within the bowl another child was
brought in to continue the testing of
scp-348 this time a boy of 10. unlike
the previous test this boy was not on
good terms with his parents and often
argued with them at the time of testing
the boy had sustained several minor
bruises the result of a small accident
that occurred while the boy had been out
riding his bike much like the little
girl this subject ate the suit that
scp-348 presented him with this time
though the bull offered a message to the
boy the lettering found on the ceramic
surface of scp-348 Simply Red don't
forget to brush messages also appeared
when an 11 year old boy with a slight
cold ate soup from the bowl this child
had been adopted by a foster family and
after eating from SCP 348 he saw the
message I'm glad you're happy appear
another young test subject a boy age six
had a similar experience in this
instance the child had several scrapes
and scratches from playing with his
friends his parents had divorced and he
was living with his mother at the time
of testing this time
scp-348's message to this boy read I'm
sorry son a seven-year-old girl
suffering from a cough was brought in
before scp-348 she had lost her father
to a traffic accident sometime before
testing commenced and received the
message I love you after finishing her
soup further testing conducted by the
foundation revealed that anyone over the
age of 18 years who attempted to eat
soup from scp-348 experienced things
slightly differently unlike the children
older subjects mostly displayed a
disinterest in finishing their meal a
common complaint among those over 18 was
that the soup was missing something
however in a few isolated cases is
testing scp-348 on older candidates
still revealed messages although the
words seemed to be faded not the clear
hand-painted blue that appeared when the
children had finished their soup one
woman aged 30 who was suffering from a
headache sat down in front of scp-348
much like it had done before the bowl
filled with soup and the woman ate as
with some of the younger subjects a key
aspect of This Woman's background seemed
to be what triggered the message to
appear specifically she admitted to
being on bad terms with her mother and
father the woman explained that she had
opted to live on her own isolating
herself from her family in fact she even
described having rejected an offer her
father made to her many years earlier
refusing some Career Training that he
was willing to give in order to help her
secure a job when she finished the soup
one word appeared in the bowl why
another woman who was 40 years old was
also brought in for the scp-348 testing
much like the previous subject she had
moved away from home and became
estranged from her parents over the
years but unlike the previous test this
woman had taken it upon herself to not
only send money to her parents but also
arranged senior care for both as well
prior to testing her father had died
peacefully of natural causes after
spending his last days in the care that
this woman had paid for as the woman ate
the soup from the bowl she remarked
about its apparently bitter taste but
also described her meal as fulfilling
after she had finished the words thank
you appeared with an scp-348 one other
adult subject that produced a noticeable
result from scp-348 was a 40 year old
male the results of this test appeared
to be the most distinctly different from
any previous adult or Child by now
researchers working for the SCP
Foundation had determined that familial
history seemed to play an important role
in the outcome of any interaction with
scp-348 and this individual was
certainly different to most the man in
question had murdered his father roughly
a year before the testing took place he
began the test with scp-348 while
Afflicted with aches in his back after
one Taste of the soup that appeared in
the Bowl before him the murderer was
immediately repulsed he complained about
the taste refusing to eat any more from
scp-348 shortly after the man began to
experience severe stomach pain the
potentially poisonous soup was disposed
of but scp-348 immediately filled with
salt water which took three hours to
disappear from the bowl despite
conducting numerous tests with subjects
of all ages and ailments the SCP
Foundation researchers have so far been
unable to determine the origins of the
messages that sometimes appear in
scp-348 some have theorized because of
the family histories of some children
and adults tested that the words somehow
come from the father of whoever eats the
soup since even when a subject's father
is alive or present in their life the
message seems to convey feelings that
their father has or would have other
researchers claim that this is just the
purpose of scp-348 to provide Comfort to
small children dealing with pain both
inside and out after all isn't providing
Comfort what a good bowl of soup
anomalous or not is best at being a
d-class for the SCP Foundation is a lot
like playing Russian roulette one day
you could be assigned to a tickle fight
with a friendly blob of slime and next
you're getting your femurs broken to
lure a sadistic old man back into his
containment chamber so when d-9781 was
told to Simply sit in an interrogation
room and wait you really didn't know
what to think but the last thing you
probably expected to see was when the
door behind him creaked open was for A
well-dressed stranger to step in this
man wasn't like any member of foundation
staff the d-class had ever seen he was a
short Caucasian man with a receding
hairline and a neat black black mustache
instead of the standard lab coat and
shirt normally seen around the facility
this man wore a black waistcoat a pair
of white gloves and a wry smile that
betrayed a Sinister intent he looked
like a butler and not just any Butler
but the quintessential Butler if you
were asked to Doodle a cartoon Butler
this would be the man you drew the
d-class almost laughed in sheer
confusion he had no idea of that in a
mere moment he would be dead now what's
the deal Jeeves he asked with a mocking
half smile but he didn't get to hear a
response the butler approached at
frightening speeds the d-class in his
last moments on Earth saw the glint of
something metallic under the overhead
lights moving too fast for him to see
what it was and then felt a sharp pain
across his throat the butler was
standing beside him now still with that
wry little smile the d-class could see
now that the butler was carrying a small
buck knife dripping with red just as he
was piecing together what had happened
to
the d-class collapsed onto the table he
was sitting at his throat expertly slit
his grisly task completed the butler
gave a polite nod and exited the room
smiling at the foundation guard standing
outside who is this man why is he
dressed like this and most importantly
why is he allowed to murder d-class
Personnel on Foundation grounds without
consequence we can answer that first
question right now because this isn't a
man at all he's the anomalous product of
scp-662 also known as the butler's
handbell first we need to go back to the
beginning and see how this anomalous
object first fell into the hands of the
SCP Foundation like a lot of anomalous
objects now under the care of the
foundation its true Origins remain
mysterious and it spent quite some time
Underground we mean that literally by
the way it was buried with its last
owner a man whose name has since been
redacted from Foundation files clutched
in this unknown man's skeletal hand and
it was extremely likely that the Bell
might never have been seen again but
then Petty thief and gray brother by the
name of George Dixon came along and dug
up the grave a simple greedy act that
has changed a number of people's lives
forever not knowing the true value of
what he held Mr Dixon made his way to a
pawn shop for his payday there the store
owner made the mistake of lifting up and
ringing the bell as if On Cue he heard
footsteps approaching behind him the
store owner turned and gasped he saw a
complete stranger emerging from the
stockroom behind him he was a short
well-dressed man smiling as he Advanced
towards him the proprietor of the pawn
shop didn't know who this guy with the
strange outfit was but he assumed he was
an accomplice of the man in his store
and that the two were trying to rob him
he grabbed a shotgun from underneath his
counter turned to the Butler and blasted
him in the chest with both barrels the
butler fell back dead and George Dixon
fled the scene in a blind Panic contrary
to what the owner may have believed
nothing that happened here had been
planned Dixon was just as surprised as
he was to see this mysterious Butler
emerge from the stockroom so what had
just happened the pawn shop owner
reported the incident to the authorities
and the butler's body was taken to the
local morgue while the Silver Bell ended
up in a police evidence Locker later
that same night things went from a
strange bungled robbery to a full-on
anomaly attracting the attention of the
SCP Foundation First the butler's body
disappeared from the morgue the second
the mortician took her eyes off of it
and then reappeared now alive in the
police storage locker why because an
unwitting Sergeant just so happened to
ring the little silver bell agent
Bradford of the SCP Foundation was
promptly on the scene he pretended to be
an FBI agent and escorted the butler off
the premises claiming that this was a
notorious escape artist who was wanted
for federal crimes in several States
things didn't go as bad effort plan
though when he discovered that the
Butler had disappeared from his
handcuffs when no one was looking agent
Bradford theorized that this had
something to do with the bell and he
confiscated it for testing later when he
rang the bell inside an SCP Containment
facility the butler turned up once more
he introduced himself as Mr Deeds and
said that he would happily perform any
service that agent Bradford required
despite being offered the phenomenal
power of a seemingly magical Butler
Bradford politely refused the offer and
instead handed the Bell over to his
superiors but don't worry agent Bradford
wasn't left completely empty-handed and
was given the esteemed SCP Foundation
had on the back award for performing
such a professional and selfless act in
service of the foundation the superior
who ended up with the Bell however
wouldn't have quite the same level of
professionalism but more on that later
the Bell cataloged as scp-662 was small
and made of pure silver with no obvious
anomalous elements at face value it was
a mere four centimeters tall and two
centimeters wide with a small
inscription reading forever mine sjw
researchers studying the Bell also noted
that it lacked its ringer but whenever
the Bell was wrong a chime would still
sound from somewhere in the room to
Signal the arrival of Mr Deeds the
anomalous Butler the object was
classified as safe and was kept in high
value storage locker 23c between uses
for experiments it's an extremely low
maintenance anomaly with the only real
requirement being a regular polish to
keep the silver from tarnishing over
time but what if Mr Deeds the mysterious
Butler summoned every time someone Rings
scp-662 the foundation needed to find
out more so he was placed under the
watchful eye of foundation researcher Dr
mirth who performed the first interview
with Mr Deeds as you can probably expect
from such a classy servant Mr Deeds was
unfair failingly polite during the
interview he always addressed Dr mirth
as sir and was extremely accommodating
within reason Mr Deeds true name
birthplace and date of birth were still
a mystery to him he could only vaguely
remember that he was of English ancestry
and that during the time of his
childhood the horse and buggy were the
most popular form of Transport when
asked about personal details or his past
Mr Deeds would often appear to become
distressed before apologizing for his
inability to remember the details the
most important piece of information that
Dr mirth obtained early on in the
interview was the primary function of Mr
Deeds he was an entity that quite
literally live to serve like a genie
being summoned from his lamp Mr Deeds
would try to perform any task that the
Summoner gave him whether it was cooking
dinner or robbing banks there were
certain limits to these Powers though
and these limits were what Dr mirth
needed to discover Dr mirth first asked
for a glass of iced tea from Mr Deeds
the butler happily obliged and left the
room walking down the hallway while
attending agents kept their eyes on him
Mr Deeds continued to merely walk
however the second they looked away the
cameras observing him malfunctioned
Deeds briefly disappeared and then
returned with a tray of iced tea Dr
mirth remarked that it was perhaps the
best iced tea he'd ever tasted Mr Deeds
couldn't recall how the tea was made
though or how he obtained it Dr mirth
next asked for a bar of gold at 99.98
Purity and Mr Deeds delivered almost the
exact level of Purity Dr mirth asked for
from this he deduced that Mr Deeds can
only perform his teleportation and
manifestation abilities when he's out of
people's direct lines of sight he soon
discovered that certain requests were
off the table though Dr mirth asked for
Mr Deeds to fetch him a blue 1963
Corvette convertible Mr Deeds did not
immediately procure the car instead
telling the doctor that such a thing was
impossible because there were too many
impractical steps involved in getting
the vehicle Dr mirth was disappointed by
this since he really wanted that car it
seemed though as Mr Deeds Powers while
enhanced by teleportation and the
ability to manifest simple objects are
limited by things that are mostly normal
and very persistent person could
conceivably do for example on Dr mirth's
orders Mr Deeds politely declined to
assassinate an Insurgent leader in the
Middle East seeing as he was too well
guarded and very far away however when
given the command he was more than
willing to head into the next room and
murder a member of d-class with a knife
Dr mirth was interested in getting a
closer look at what was going on with Mr
Deeds biology and so asked him to slit
his own throat with the same knife he
used to murder the d-class Mr Deeds
politely obliged commenting before he
did to Dr mirth that had been an
absolute pleasure serving him the body
was kept within an agent's line of sight
at all time until the autopsy could be
performed just to make sure it didn't
disappear the autopsy showed that there
was nothing inherently anomalous about
the physiology of Mr Deeds and he would
appear as good as new the next time the
bell rang things took an even stranger
turn after that though despite it
appearing like the foundation now knew
everything they needed to know about Mr
Deeds and the scp-662 bell Dr mirth
insisted on performing further studies
into what exactly Mr Deeds was capable
of for example he requested a deep
tissue massage and found that it
completely cured his back pain Dr mirth
also asked Mr Deeds to clean his car and
found that it was clean to a truly
impeccable standard during his tenure as
the lead researcher on the 662 project
he also asked to receive a haircut from
Mr Deeds and found out that while Mr
Deeds excelled at many tasks he made a
pretty bad Barber he was great at
laundry though Dr mirth was eventually
removed from 662 Duty by the o5 council
once it became clear his research had
just become an excuse for Mr Deeds to do
errands and chores for him of course Mr
Deeds had no complaints either way
whether it's serving up delicious tea
cleaning a certain selfish researcher's
home or murdering a d-class personnel
with a buck knife one thing cannot be
denied Mr Deeds is one hell of a butler
it was the year 2000 and seven-year-old
zenya Chao was like a lot of children
her age bright but ignored she had a
youthful enthusiasm for knowledge and
learning and with the right
encouragement it was obvious she'd go on
to do great things but her parents were
both working two jobs apiece to make
ends meet so outside of school hours
little zenya spent a lot of her time
alone she learned to cook and clean for
herself since it would often be way past
her bedtime when her parents finally got
home from work they communicated largely
through sticky notes left for her on the
fridge before they left for work in the
morning it would be easy for someone
like Zen to fall through the cracks her
potential wasted and get forced into the
same endless Rat Race as her parents and
that probably would have happened if her
brush with
scp-1594 hadn't changed the course of
her life forever like a lot of parents
who couldn't spend as much time with
their children as they'd like Mr and Mrs
Chow gave zenya occasional gifts as a
way to try and make up for their absence
mostly they gave zenya new books to add
to a growing collection but their
two-bedroom apartment only had so much
space for books a year ago the family
had bought a new desktop computer to
share these days this would be the
answer to a lonely bookworm's prayers
but the internet was still in its
infancy back then everything changed
when her parents bought her a copy of
the Miss Jay's Wiz Kids Schoolhouse
CD-ROM Miss Jay's Wizkid Schoolhouse was
never a popular program produced by
shoot the moon software in 1999 the game
sold poorly on the CD-ROM market for
five years until the company filed for
bankruptcy in two thousand four but that
didn't matter to zenya as far as she was
concerned receiving a copy of Miss Jay's
Wiz kid Schoolhouse was nothing short of
a miracle and she was far more right
than she knew she didn't have just any
piece of primitive educational software
on her hands zenya Chao was playing with
magic after the software loaded a
cheerful figure appeared on zenya's
monitor this was Miss J A stylized 2D
teacher in a low res but colorful 3D
classroom what can you learn from Miss
Jay well pretty much anything and zenya
as a lonely kid without many friends had
all the time in the world she spent days
on end learning from Miss Jay and soon
zenya went from a bright child to a bona
fide child genius her largely absent
parents barely even noticed when their
child started demonstrating an advanced
knowledge of mechanical engineering and
a newfound fluency in Swahili daily and
not only did Miss Jay now known to zenya
as Miss Joyce teacher students with
Supernatural Effectiveness she also
seemed almost like she was alive
warm calm encouraging figure who took a
genuine personal enthusiasm in the
education and happiness of her students
more than many real teachers even but
sadly not all good things last forever
when zenya turned 12 her family bought a
new computer and the old Miss Jay's Wiz
kid Schoolhouse CD-ROM was no longer
compatible with the new operating system
the disc gathered dust in the closet
while zenya passed through high school
and then got into a prestigious college
she received her PhD several years
earlier than expected and showed such
promise in her scientific field that a
certain organization took notice you
guessed it the SCP Foundation the
foundation is only interested in adding
the best and brightest to their ranks
and thanks to the tutoring from Miss Jay
zenya Chao certainly fit the bill she
was assigned to the role of Junior
researcher and little did she know she
was about to run into an old friend in
her new line of work the foundation
first discovered evidence of Miss Jay's
anomalous qualities while researching a
series of strange Forum posts in 2012.
on a thread discussing abandonware which
is software for which official support
is no longer available there were
multiple reports of a so-called living
character in an old CD ROM many of them
had owned as children seeing as the
technology to use the CD-ROM was
obsolete shoot the moons had reportedly
extremely low sales for the title and
nobody on the Forum had kept their copy
the foundation classified this apparent
anomaly as neutralized no problem that
was until then Junior researcher zenya
Chao was briefed on this particular SCP
10 years later she remembered exactly
what the Forum posters were talking
about and what's more she still had her
old copy at home the senior Foundation
researchers were astounded an
opportunity to study this forgotten
anomaly had had just fallen into their
laps and it was all thanks to their
brilliant new Junior researcher zenya
superiors ordered her to bring in her
copy of the Miss Jay's Wiz Kids
Schoolhouse CD-ROM and then real testing
began and after rigorous examination of
the software it appears by all accounts
that Miss J really is the world's
greatest teacher in spite of the fact
she's a collection of pixels on a basic
CD-ROM program from the tail end of the
90s what Miss J seemed to specialize in
was intensive courses she had the
ability to make students certifiable
experts in almost any subject through
courses that can last upwards of 30
hours and spread out over just a few
days but this isn't a student's become
so enraptured in learning that they
forget accounting for their most basic
needs and experience a decline in
process story Miss Jay's lesson plans
account for regular bathroom meal and
even Recreation breaks for students her
talents easily account for zenya chao's
remarkable academic success the same
success that got her picked up by the
SCP Foundation naturally if they had a
technology on their hands that could
reliably create experts and Geniuses
with seemingly no negative consequences
the foundation knew that Miss J and what
she had to teach could be immensely
valuable in their mission to effectively
secure contain and protect other
anomalies but we're not talking about
the chaos Insurgency here the foundation
would never start to use an anomaly for
their own benefit without proper testing
so that's exactly what they did their
experiments on scp-1594 began at site 15
and after ascertaining that Miss J pose
no real threat to her students they
recruited a local elementary school to
provide human test subjects closer to
miss Jay's intended demographic the
foundation found that there were a few
constraints between every lesson given
by Miss J to one of her student
before teaching the really
mind-blowingly complex stuff she would
always begin with a basic primer on
letters colors and numbers to make sure
she and her students were all on the
same page another constant was that all
our students would refer to her as some
variation of Miss J with examples
including the names Miss Julie Miss
Jenny and Miss Joy one experiment was
performed on Amy Myers a little girl
from the third grade her academic
records showed she was a bright and
eager student but she was described by
her teachers as being especially shy Amy
referred to miss Jay as Miss Janie and
asked to be given a lesson on her
favorite animal cats of course Miss Jay
gladly obliged and gave Amy a 15-hour
lesson split over the course of two days
which the foundation closely observed by
the time the lesson was completed the
results were truly astonishing Amy
demonstrated knowledge of feline
Behavior diet and physiology on the
level of professional animal behavioral
scientists she became upset when the
session ended and the program was
switched off having become attached to
miss Jay no further anomalous effects
were reported the next subject was a
student from the second grade named
Devon Williams Devon had a poor academic
record and behavioral issues stemming
from several learning disabilities in
the past teachers had reported Devon
having real difficulty engaging with
their lessons and the foundation wanted
to see if Miss Jay's Supernatural
teaching abilities fared any better
Devon chose to be educated on the
subject of trains and was given a
15-hour course on the subject spread
over two days Devon had no difficulty
engaging with these lessons and after
their conclusion he displayed a level of
knowledge on Railway engineering
comparable to a graduate level education
on the subject Devon was so engaged in
his lessons that he had to be physically
removed from the room once the core had
completed because he'd become so
attached to his new teacher the
foundation was feeling extremely
optimistic about the prospect of using
Miss J to train potential recruits
seeming as she seemed to be able to
teach even the most difficult juvenile
subjects however the foundation needed
to prove that Miss Jay could be just as
effective teaching adults for the next
test they recruited
d-14417 a 24 year old member of d-class
personnel who described himself as a
poor student and tested poorly on
pre-screening attentiveness and focus
evaluations he was the perfect candidate
for the first adult test of Miss J to
the Delight of the foundation higher-ups
d-14417xl Miss J made him a verifiable
expert in law and he was able to pass a
mock bar exam with a grade of 310 after
his course much like the children he
felt intense sadness once the experiment
ended stating that Miss J was the best
teacher he had ever had he's since been
selectively anesthetized released and is
pursuing a degree in criminal law with
his new knowledge needless to say the
foundation was impressed the last thing
they needed to know was who exactly this
Miss J truly was to do this they'd
conduct an interview and thankfully they
already had someone who had a
pre-established rapport with the subject
zenya Chao when zenya began the
interview Miss Jay recognized her
immediately she was delighted to see one
of her students go on to find such
success in her chosen field zenya
questioned Miss Jay on what she truly
was and Miss Jay responded that she
honestly wasn't sure all she knew for
sure was that she was passionate about
helping lonely children who love to
learn Embrace their education that's
really all there was to it and it
appears she was telling the truth so far
the foundation has found nothing that
hints at a nefarious motivation behind
Miss Jay's actions it would appear she
truly does just want to help children
zenya touched by the kindness that this
safe class anomaly showed her as a
neglected child and having now seen the
positive impact that she had on children
like her thanked Miss J for all she'd
done and left the interview happy that
there was an SCP out there who just
wanted to change people's lives for the
better and probably all of us would be a
little better off if there were more
after all this was one of the few scps
who changed a few good people's lives
for the better and all of us can
probably learn something from the
kindness and patience of Miss Jay down
in the depths of facility 23 a group of
scientists stand before a massive
rumbling piece of Machinery they all
hold their breath as the gigantic
mechanism suddenly stops it's really
quiet for a moment before a door slides
open the scientists crane their necks to
see inside to see what the result of
their great experiment was these were
some of the greatest Minds in the SCP
Foundation but nothing could prepare
them for what they had created September
9 2008 was an unseasonably Frosty day
when Dr Charles gears one of the SCP
foundation's most iconic scientists
parked his Honda Civic outside of what
seemed like an innocuous government Cold
Storage Warehouse he sipped his coffee
and surveyed the building which she
along with about a hundred others in
total knew to be site 19 facility 23.
why was Dr gears former director of all
Euclid level containment at site 19 here
today because official testing was about
to begin on
scp-914 the foundation had acquired the
machine now known as scp-914 some time
ago but only after its recent
reclassification to 914 had it been
relocated to facility 23. it must have
been important because the entirety of
the facility was being repurposed for
scp-914 research they were dealing with
an immensely complicated piece of
anomalous technology here and the same
question was on everybody's limbs what
exactly does this thing do Dr Arthur
Hackett the facility director had
requested the cold clinical assistance
of Dr gears in providing the answer once
he'd finish his morning coffee Dr gears
headed inside the facility security
chief agent Alan sedna had been beefing
up security at the building and at least
two mobile task force units were already
on call in case anything happened the
first day of official testing is always
a crap shoot you might get a nice drink
out of it like with scp-294 or you may
get an XK Class end of the world
scenario
never really know all Dr gears knew as
he walked up the granite steps to the
main entrance was that he was already
feeling exhausted when you've dealt with
anomalous objects and entities for
decades on end the sense of wonder and
Mystery Begins to wear off only to be
replaced with a kind of tedium any
office worker knows all too well
everyone knew that Dr gears was devoted
to the job perhaps more than anyone else
but he approached the job with an
emotionless effect you wouldn't know
from looking at him if he was thinking
about the deadly anomalous creature in
the Next Room or what he was going to
have for lunch that day the doctor
passed through security and was briefed
in the break room by Dr Lucius Veritas
director of research at site 19. he
explained that the machine seemed to
work in the absence of any power source
its mechanical structure is similar to
Machinery from the Industrial Revolution
but it's exceedingly complex for
something constructed in that time
Foundation analyzes into the structure
of the 914 machine have shown it to have
as many as a 8 million moving parts and
that might even be an incomplete
estimate Dr Gears War is trademark blank
phase as he listened solemnly nodded and
asked to be shown the anomaly
he was led into containment chamber 109b
by a pair of guards according to all
current Foundation tests the machine
doesn't appear to pose any active risk
of containment breach or danger to the
guards earning it the rare safe
designation as a result aside from
guards stationed on site containment
procedures for 914 were minimal whether
this designation would need to be
changed after testing was something Dr
gears would soon find out
scp-914 was a truly impressive sight to
Behold a giant Clockwork mechanism
taking up around 18 square feet with an
unfathomably complex combination of
screw drives belts pulleys Springs and
gears a less stoic researcher might see
the humor in recruiting a doctor gears
to test such a device but comedy
definitely wasn't one of Dr Gear's
Specialties he stared at the machine
with a detached Fascination analyzing
its vital components at a glance
gears noted a large mainspring beneath a
rudimentary selection panel the panel is
copper with a large selection knob fixed
to an arrow above a series of different
options rough coarse one-to-one fine and
very fine
there was also a large key below the
selection panel for the purposes of
winding up the mainspring and initiating
whatever procedure this machine was
designed to enact next Dr gears noticed
two large booths connected to the
Machine by a pair of equally large
copper tubes the booth on the left
labeled intake and the right labeled
output incredibly Dr gears was able to
immediately deduce the purpose of this
machine it was designed to enact some
kind of transformative process on
whatever was placed into the intake
Booth but what kind of transformative
process that's exactly what Dr gears was
here to find out the experiment was
simple they would gather a series of
samples both inanimate objects and
living tissue and use them to explore
the different permutations of the 914
machines transformative abilities this
initial series of experiments were
approved by o5 command and the site
director and with the 47 researchers
present in facility 23 at his disposal
Dr gears commenced his research into
scp-914 to minimize risk Dr gears
decided the first test would be a simple
kilogram of Steel on his orders the
steel was placed into the intake Booth
with the doctor's approval a junior
researcher set the control panel setting
to rough and began twisting the main
spring key at which point the booth
stores closed and a small bell inside
Shine the machine began to rumble its 8
million working pieces churning into
life it continued like this for around
10 minutes before falling silent at
which point the output Booth opened what
had once been a single lump of Steel
weighing one kilogram was now an uneven
pile of smaller lumps with evidence of
laser cutting doctor gears May note of
the fact that having lasers within such
a machine is both anachronistic and
anomalous and that the rough setting
appears to messily cleave the object
placed within the intake Booth into
pieces Dr gears also noted that it would
be unwise to test any kind of explosive
material on the rough setting unless of
course they wanted to destroy the build
thing the research continued Dr gears
used another one kilogram lump of Steel
to test the one-to-one feature this time
the result was far more peculiar the
output Booth contained the exact same
weight in steel screws this result was
sparking even greater connections and
Doctor Gear's impressive analytical mind
firstly the one-to-one feature caused
the 914 machine to transform the output
into something different from but
similar to the intake and while this
would require further testing it
appeared that the 914 machine despite
being anomalous does still follow the
laws of physics samples pass through the
machine conserve their mass and would
not be transmuted on an atomic level
from one element to another
next Dr gears pushed another lump of
Steel through the machine on the fine
setting the result this time was a
kilogram of Steel carpet tax from this
Dr gears was able to ascertain that the
fine feature improves the samples placed
within the intake Booth somewhat however
things got even stranger when gears
performed the same experiment on the
very fine setting the output Booth
provided several unknown gases and a
lump of unknown metal with anomalous
qualities namely it was resistant to
heat up to 50 000 degrees impossible to
bend or break with any force and was a
perfect conductor of electricity
Dr gear suddenly realized his task here
may be more interesting than he'd
initially imagined was that a bit of a
smile on his face that one researcher
spotted surely not this was the famous
unflappable Dr gears after all the
doctor decided to take it up a notch and
began to test more complex items in the
914 machine he removed his own
wristwatch and placed it into the input
Booth before setting the machine to
coarse and letting her rip literally in
this case
when the output Booth was opened the
watch had been painstakingly
disassembled into its component parts
with no damage to said Parts Dr gears
noted the course feature as a more mild
version of the rough in the sense that
it was able to take an object apart
without any kind of fundamental damage
he also made note of the fact he'd need
to get himself a new watch Dr gears then
asked one of the researchers to
surrender their cell phone for testing
while none were excited at the prospect
of their phone getting eviscerated by A
Clockwork Behemoth one of the
researchers eventually surrendered their
Blackberry Curve to the doctor
he placed it into the intake booth on
the one-to-one setting and 10 minutes
later the output Booth released a brand
new Apple iPhone sadly for the
researcher who donated his BlackBerry he
wasn't allowed to keep the new device
naturally Dr gears was interested in
trying out the anomalous very fine
setting on a more complex object seeing
as no other researchers were eager to
hand over their personal effects he took
a Colt Python revolver from a member of
security and rammed that through the
machine on very fine
the result was an extremely powerful
energy weapon containing gamma radiation
which fired a beam capable of
disintegrating anything in its path
while the weapon's power was immense it
was also too dangerous and unstable to
be added to the foundation's Armory for
General use
having collected a wealth of data from
more complex objects Dr gears was eager
to move to the next stage live test
subjects
while his fellow researchers had some
reservations the experiments pushed on
beginning with mice a single white mouse
was put into the intake booth on the
one-to-one setting and the Machine was
activated
the result five minutes later was an
almost identical creature saved for the
fact that it now had brown fur
encouraged by the fact that the mouse
survived the refinery process Dr gears
next applied for the use of two chimps
in his scp-914 experiments
the first chimp was run through the
machine on the fine setting the result
was a chimp of human level intelligence
who has since begun working for the
foundation under the Alias Dr Bobo and
the data from this test has been
expunged from the official reports to
protect Dr Bobo's privacy the second
primate test this time on rough was not
quite as positive the chimp was
dismembered with the mutilated corpse
showing evidence of cutting from high
heat and crushing
of course everyone knew where these
tests were eventually going Dr gears
requested two members of d-class
personnel for testing the first was a 42
year old Caucasian male weighing 108
kilograms and standing 185 centimeters
tall Dr gears ran him through scp-914 on
the one-to-one setting resulting in a
slightly taller Hispanic man with a
slightly lower body weight
he immediately became severely confused
and agitated and attempted to attack the
guards present leading to his
unfortunate termination by Foundation
staff it was on the final live test that
tragedy truly struck a 28 year old
Caucasian male was run through the
machine on the highly anomalous very
fine setting the result was an utterly
nightmarish creature
so horrifying that the majority of the
details on its physical appearance have
been expunged from the Rapport the
creature made a sudden Escape reaching
the relatively minor containment
procedures intended for the inert
scp-914 this highly dangerous creature
killed eight guards as well as two
senior researchers upon emerging from
the output Booth a special response team
was dispatched to take the creature down
but that proved harder than expected
scp-914 had massively improved upon the
human original especially when it came
to its killing ability eventually it was
captured but the Special Response Team
suffered injuries and memory loss as a
result of the creature's anomalous
powers
the creature was also severely wounded
and its blood caused corrosive damage to
the plumbing in facility 23. the
creature expired from its injuries
several hours later turning into a cloud
of Blue Ash that blinded a nearby
research team Dr gears would later
comment that the experiments were
ultimately still a success in spite of
some minor hiccups testing on the device
continues to this day in an effort to
understand the full potential of the
machine though for obvious reasons
biological testing on the machine has
since been forbidden without direct
authorization from o5 command after all
if an already dangerous SCP was ever
subjected to the very fine
transformation setting we could be
dealing with something beyond our
greatest nightmares it's an unusually
calm moment in the SCP Foundation no one
is in the hall besides a scientist and a
young female subject there are no tests
going on just observation
the scientist calmly asks her questions
as he escorts her down the hallway
hoping to get more insight into her
unique abilities so why does she look so
utterly terrified as the scientist tries
to get her attention the young woman
becomes more preoccupied staring
nervously around the hallway does she
fear the scientist why does she keep
muttering strange phrases that don't
make any sense how do they break through
such a heavy door a door is nearly a
foot thick how did it manage to destroy
it the scientist is looking at his notes
and tries to make sense of the young
woman's statements when he notices
something terrible she's staring at one
of the doors containing another highly
dangerous SCP in top of the line
restraints but it's safely locked away
right the scientist swears he can hear
the sound of scratching behind the steel
door it was 17 hours later when the
dangerous SCP broke out of its
containment cell and could have laid
ways to the entire SCP container
facility if it wasn't for the heavily
armed Response Team waiting outside to
contain it and return it to itself the
huge loss of life was only avoided
because the SCP Foundation had advanced
warning all thanks to the greatest
secret weapon the foundation has ever
seen
scp-187 But the foundation's most
powerful defense against dangerous scps
is probably its most unlikely a
completely normal looking young woman in
her early 20s whose only distinguishing
characteristic is how thin and haunted
she looks despite being no danger to
anyone in the foundation she's one of
the most carefully guarded scps in the
facility to protect her from herself
scp-187 is one of the most powerful
precognitives ever found but her
abilities are a danger to her own mind
this average looking girl has a unique
telepathic ability where she can see
into the future of whatever she's
looking at seeing it simultaneously in
two frames of existence she sees it as
it is now as well as what it will look
like in the future say for instance
she's looking at a baby tiger cub oh
cute
at the same time she also sees the
massive fearsome jungle beast it'll
become she won't see minor changes to
its state so she won't be able to tell
you how your next haircut will look but
if something drastic is about to happen
to someone or something she'll be able
to predict it with perfect accuracy
there's only one problem
she can't turn it off
this involuntary ability goes off
whenever she sees someone or something
that's about to undergo a major change
in its status this means that at any
time she can be bombarded with horrible
visuals and that even include food
ever since her abilities kicked in
scp-187 has been unable to eat normally
because whatever she eats or drinks she
sees it in its future State when she
looks at a glass of water she'll see it
as a liquid but a little more yellow
than it usually is
as for solid food she'll see it as what
it comes out as after it's been digested
not exactly appetizing so for a while it
looked like she was likely to starve
herself to death in the foundation's
custody fortunately the administration
scientists were able to find some
workarounds around her ability feeding
and hydrating her intravenously was an
option but further study of her
abilities made clear that her power was
processed through her eyes that means
that when she's blindfolded she's able
to eat without her precognition kicking
in being assigned to the detail for
scp-187 is very different from most SCP
details if you're assigned to scp-682
you're constantly worried that the
horrible carnivorous Beast with a hatred
for all things human is going to get
loose and tear you to shreds not so much
with scp-187 this duty is more like a
medical team where the patient is highly
valuable to the institution and can't be
allowed to get free or to harm
themselves in any way the foundation has
taken the highest precautions to ensure
scp-187 is safe including a set of
medical restraints that she's strapped
into except when out of her cell are
participating in tests even when given
more freedom her hands are always in
soft mittens to keep her from trying to
damage her own eyes as a way to
neutralize her powers her team
blindfolds her before every meal time
and feeds her with some mild sedatives
added to her food to keep her calm
through assistant care she's starting to
recover from her self-induced starvation
the Personnel chosen for this assignment
are carefully screened before being sent
in to interact with her they need to be
the most responsible and detail-oriented
members of the staff who won't miss a
thing when it comes to her care routine
just because 187 is harmless doesn't
mean she can't move fast and one misstep
could cost the foundation their most
valuable asset
and unlike most scps 187 is rarely
handled by d-class Personnel they don't
have access to higher security specimens
and they don't have the training due to
their short tenure but there's another
reason the foundation keeps 187 away
from the lowest men on the totem pole
d-class Personnel are frequently used to
test out dangerous scps and are lucky if
they get to end their service intact
when she was exposed to some d-class
Personnel early in her stay she saw them
as horribly bloated with holes in their
heads or missing half their body those
unfortunate Personnel soon met horrible
Fates sucked out into the vacuum of
space shot while trying to escape and
bitten in half by an escaping anomalous
creature additionally While most d-class
Personnel are anesthetized after their
service some are terminated for breaking
protocol or trying to escape
scp-187 would see any of these
unfortunate Personnel walking around as
the corpses they'd wind up as the the
foundation wants to learn the full
extent of her powers though and this
means tests lots of tests when she first
came into the foundation's care they
were focused on figuring out how her
power worked they gave her IQ tests and
she got every answer right on the
written test her IQ was measured as
being off the charts at least 300 which
would make her the smartest person alive
but her normal behavior didn't seem to
match up with this level of super
intelligence confusing them even more
when she was given a computerized IQ
test she scored slightly below average
with a score of 97. the scientists
assigned to her case studied the results
and created other tests until they
understood how her precognitive ability
works
we can see the future of anything that's
physically affected so when an answer is
marked down on a piece of paper that's a
notable change but when an entry is
typed into a computer the computer
Remains the Same so her ability wasn't
able to help her on the computerized
tests but her abilities could still help
the foundation especially when it comes
to improving security for other
anomalies she had inadvertently
prevented The Escape of an especially
deadly SCP creature by predicting it
would break through the door but how
would her powers manifest in more
complicated cases some Foundation
researchers postulated that she might be
able to see into the future of deadly
indestructible anomalies like scp-682
and figure out a way to eliminate it but
temporal experts warned this could
create a paradox
after all she would be looking at an
elimination protocol that didn't exist
until she looked at it but her powers
and how they might help in other ways
other than neutralization warranted
further exploration so Personnel were
assigned and the scp-187 experiments
began
scp-162 is a horrible mass of Fish Hooks
wire and other sharp implements it
exudes a psychological pull and any
unfortunate person who touches it winds
up being pulled in by the barbed objects
and absorbed into its mass
scp-187 was kept at a safe distance and
examined it and was undisturbed she saw
it only as a pile of melted slag
indicating that it would be neutralized
at some point
scp-529 a normal and friendly cat except
for the fact that its back half appears
to be completely missing the cat acts as
if it's whole and when scp-187 was
exposed to it she didn't seem to notice
anything wrong with the cat she played
with it briefly and seemed to be calmer
than any other time she was examined the
foundation is considering using scp-529
as a motivating tool after she requested
to revisit it other tasks had much more
disturbing results as scp-187 discovered
things about subjects that researchers
were previously unaware of
scp-003 a strange organic circuit board
made of hair and nails attached to a
stone tablet appears to be an ancient
machine but when scp-187 was introduced
to it she greeted it like a person and
had a conversation with it as the staff
looked on confused when she was
interviewed after she described The
Entity as a very nice lady what is
scp-003 evolving into the foundation is
studying it closely thanks to scp-187's
advance warning when exposed to scp-015
a massive network of pipes that seems to
be slowly growing and defends itself
from any attempts to work on it with
tools
scp-187 observed few differences from
its current state until she opened the
door inside she reported a massive
network of pipes Reaching For Miles with
no end in sight
scp-015 had been reduced to a manageable
site and its danger had been contained
but scp-187 indicated that it may be
getting ready for its biggest and most
dangerous expansion yet
scp-415 a seemingly normal human man
with an ability to regenerate his
internal organs has been a subject of
the foundation's investigation since his
arrival particularly due to the strange
physical alterations he underwent to
make it easier to access his organs he's
one of the more peaceful scps at the
foundation but as soon as scp-187 was
exposed to him she became Disturbed she
begged to be removed from the room and
upon interrogation revealed that she saw
scp-415 as a deceased corpse what is
going to happen to the seemingly
Immortal man
scp-187 was also exposed to some of the
more dangerous scps in the foundation
including
SCP-173 a seemingly living statue that
moves in unpredictable ways whenever it
isn't observed and has been responsible
for the deaths of many d-class personnel
who enter its enclosure for cleaning but
it seems to be stable in containment so
why when exposed to it did scp-187 begin
screaming immediately have to be removed
from the enclosure and fall into a
catatonic state for two days she
remembered nothing from the vision she
had of the statue and it took days for
her to recover fully the foundation is
keeping a close eye on the Statue even
closer than they were before
[Music]
scp-106 also known as the old man had a
brave killer resembling an elderly
rotting corpse is known for its frequent
escapes and sadistic attacks on anyone
near it when exposed to scp-187 the
observation lasted less than a minute
before the old man attempted to escape
scp-187 looked to be in direct Danger
from the old man but he never touched
her or harmed her in any way when she
was interviewed after she explained that
the old man wanted an audience someone
to watch it the incident was recorded as
a close call and an indication that some
of the other entities may have their own
plans for scp-187
scp-187's power Works without fail and
that tempts many people to try to use
her to get answers to important
questions but they should be careful
what they wish for as one doctor found
out during an examination
scp-187 looked at the woman's hand and
observed that it was odd that she wasn't
wearing her wedding ring but the doctor
was and had been for the last 19 years
but the next day her husband filed for
divorce and scp-187's prophecies proved
once again correct
so what are the future plans for scp-187
the foundation is being careful with her
abilities both to preserve her sanity
and to prevent any potential time
paradoxes a routine has been established
to keep her safe fed and protected from
some of the worst effects of her ability
but the experiments using her Visions
aren't going to stop anytime soon many
of her Visions predicted dangerous new
Evolutions in ketter class anomalies
giving the team time to prepare and up
security measures no one knows where
scp-187 came from or what the source of
her unique abilities is but while the
SCP Foundation is keeping some of the
most dangerous entities in the world
safely locked away their most valuable
asset may be one of the most harmless
because as long as scp-187 has her
Visions the next breakout or apocalyptic
event can be stopped in its tracks
before it happens a man is sitting in a
chair inside a containment cell at the
SCP Foundation the man is dressed
normally and he isn't trying to escape
tape or attack the researchers who are
observing him the only thing that makes
this man different from you or I is that
he ages right in front of us going from
a teenager to an old man in a matter of
minutes at first glance
scp-1007 looks very normal just a corpse
lying in a standard coffin well the
corpse of an old man in a coffin being
kept locked up in a containment chamber
is normal when compared to some of the
other strange anomalies that are found
in the SCP foundation's archives inside
the coffin with
scp-1007 is a small Metal Key and this
is quite literally the key to seeing
what makes this anomaly so special on
scp-1007's back between his shoulder
blades is a small Keyhole x-ray scans of
1007 have shown that the keyhole is just
an empty socket it's unconnected to
anything there's no internal Clockwork
mechanisms or other Machinery that
should be able to be activated by a key
when the metal key that is kept in s
cp1007's coffin classified as
scp-1007-1 is inserted into the keyhole
on 1007's back in turn something truly
incredible happens as the key is turned
scp-1007 undergoes a change unlike
anything the SCP Foundation has seen
before with each turn of the key the
subject's physical age is reversed by
one full year Foundation researchers are
able to watch 1007 age in Reverse in
real time even any Decay that had set in
on the corpse is completely reversed and
disappears as the key is wound in 1007
gets younger and younger as the key is
turned 1007 will continue to de-age
physically compacting and shrinking down
until it appears to have the form of a
newborn human child it's unknown where
the physical mass of 1007's body goes to
since this should defy the laws of
physics but those laws we assume to be a
Bedrock of our our universe's reality
are often more of a suggestion when it
comes to anomalies the SCP Foundation
deals with Once
scp-1007 reaches the newborn baby stage
it will suddenly reactivate coming to
life immediately regardless of how long
it has been dead and lying in its coffin
once 1007 is brought back to life he
will go through the entire human life
cycle within a 75 minute period
experiencing what looks to be
approximately one year of normal human
growth and development for every minute
that passes that means that in the
course of about 16 minutes researchers
will see
scp-1007 change from a crying infant to
a fully grown teenager as you can
imagine the subject has reported feeling
excruciating pain during these first few
minutes as his bones rapidly lengthen
and expand and as muscles develop and
change shape dramatically
scp-1007 is able to watch with his young
eyes as his bones move and set
themselves into place lay lengthening
and widening in seconds during growth
spurts that normally take months or
years after about five minutes provided
his legs have grown to the same length
at the same time he's usually able to
prop himself up and stand at around 10
minutes the pain really starts the bones
crack and ache as they grow at their
fastest for the whole cycle hair will
also grow on his face and body and he
can't help but feel some amount of Shame
and embarrassment at what's happening to
him in front of the foundation
researchers who are taking copious notes
by 20 minutes he can hardly think due to
the pain at this point he usually lies
down and curls into a ball whispering to
himself that it will all be over soon
that the pain won't last forever after
another 10 minutes he's right the pain
is almost stopped completely by the
30-minute mark But now as wrinkles and
stretch marks start to set in a
different kind of pain reveals itself as
scp-1007 realizes that he must watch
himself die 40 minutes in and he starts
to reflect on his past the life he was
forced to lead as a kind of Sideshow
freak more on that later though the
physical Decay happens faster now warts
and moles and other marks of age
appearing on his skin after 50 minutes
he is aware that over half of his life
has passed and he is reaching the end
his hair starts to fall out as do his
teeth which he's never actually been
able to use as he's never tasted food as
the 60 Minute Mark comes and goes he
begins to feel grateful for the coming
end with the escape from Pain and the
rest it would bring his body has become
very wrinkled by this point and is
covered with age spots his eyes begin to
Cloud severely limiting his ability to
see and his hearing gets weaker and
weaker until he can't comprehend
anything the researchers say at 75
minutes it's all over
scp-1007's body expires and he dies once
again he will remain as a corpse until
the metal key is inserted into his back
and the whole process starts once again
just as there appears to be no
explanation for where the mass of
scp-1007's body goes as the key is wound
during the reversal process so too is
there no explanation for where the
energy needed for his rapid growth comes
from this process should violate the
first law of thermodynamics and
Foundation researchers are very curious
about the underlying process the one
constant that remains on
scp-1007's body is a small tattoo on his
right calf where the words Mr life and
Mr death from Little misters by Dr
wondertainment appear this matches up
with entry number 11 on document
scp-909 which lists a total of 20 little
misters
scp-1007 was recovered by task force Tau
6 during a raid on a mansion in
California along with several other
anomalous creatures and objects
the owner of the Mansion claimed that he
acquired
scp-1007 at an auction hosted by
Marshall Carter and dark Limited
Marshall Carter and dark limited is a
club based in London England that is
famed for collecting and selling what it
would describe as rare and obscure
objects unfortunately this often
includes various anomalies that should
be under the care of the SCP Foundation
and the club's mission to provide its
members with exclusive expensive and
rare experiences means that they're
often in conflict with the foundation
and they have even been responsible for
several containment breaches
Marshall Carter and dark limited
continues to be a very secretive
organization and the name of the
director and a list of its members have
so far been very difficult to obtain at
the auction they hosted where scp-1007
was offered for sale there were
apparently along with Mr life and death
at least four other misters for sale
though the identity of the other buyers
and which little misters they may have
purchased is still under investigation
the fact that
scp-1007 has the name Mr life and Mr
death seems to imply that he may have
originally been part of a set though
this counterpart little Mister has yet
to be recovered or even identified in
interviews with
scp-1007 he has given his own personal
theory that he embodies both names and
the designation is a reference to the
way he alternates between life and death
however the possibility Still Remains
though that he may have a twin of sorts
and the foundation continues to
investigate its possible identity and
location
scp-1007's brief 75-minute life followed
by a death that lasts until he is
rewound by a special key means that he
is easily contained and has been
classified as safe he is only to be
activated during routine testing and
After experiencing death he is to be
placed back into his coffin along with
the key in keeping with current
regulations for all anomalies that have
been designated as misters
scp-1007 is to be contained in Hall 8 of
site 13 for additional observation and
study it was November 3rd 1991 and Blake
Newsome loved his job he had a passion
for organization an Undying Love of
American political history and was a
lifelong member of the Republican party
that's why he took great pride in his
position as a filing clerk at the Ronald
Reagan Presidential Library or at least
he did until his horrifying encounter
with
scp-1981 the worst day of Blake's life
began like any other he was taking
inventory of the archives wide array of
betamax tapes and making sure that they
were all arranged carefully and
conformed with the filing system one by
one he checked footage of speeches and
addresses off of his list until he came
upon a strange tape that had no business
being there the tape looked to be
completely normal but it hadn't been
recorded on the archive inventory and
there was something else off about it a
single white sticker was on the front of
the tape with Ronald Reagan cut up while
talking squalled hastily with what was
probably a felt tip marker
Blake was shocked in appalled they
hadn't even spelled the president's name
correctly
what poor Mr Newsome didn't know was
that he was about to see something so
disturbing that he'd look back on that
misspelling like it was a treasured
childhood memory
standard policy for tapes like this
would be to review and catalog or even
throw it out if necessary typically a
lowly filing clerk like Blake would need
to seek approval from his superiors but
curiosity got the better of him he
commandeered one of the library's
televisions and betamax cassette players
and started watching the footage for the
first minute or so nothing seemed out of
the ordinary
just the president standing at the
podium giving his iconic evil empire
speech to the National Association of
evangelicals at Sheraton Twin Towers
Hotel Orlando Florida on March 8 1983.
however the second the tape hit the one
minute and 10 seconds Mark something
unnatural began to occur President
Reagan's speech began to Veer off as the
topic of conversation shifted from the
importance of family values to the
Exquisite Taste of human flesh Blake was
taken aback surely he was hearing things
but the tape only got worse President
Reagan began to divulge the fact that he
enjoyed the taste of young flesh the
best particularly that of infants as
Reagan began to go into detail about how
exactly one should best cook an infant
if you want to seal in the flavor the
crowd erupted into modest Applause Blake
started to feel sick he'd remembered
watching this speech and President
Reagan had said nothing of the sore
things only got weirder as the
president's cheek suddenly opened up
into a long bleeding gash as though
someone had cut into his face with an
invisible knife has the speech continued
and Reagan's words became more
nonsensical and incoherent the injuries
got worse too his face developed
puncture wounds like he was being
stabbed skin in some areas rotted and
peeled off Reagan showed no awareness of
the horrifying injuries that seemed to
be occurring spontaneously on his body
this was a living nightmare the tape
came to a merciful end 22 minutes in
after President Reagan's throat appeared
to be slashed open and his insane speech
was reduced to quiet gurgles
it fizzled out into static shortly after
and Blake politely retired to the
bathroom to throw up
was this some sick prank or tampering or
camera trickery perhaps he didn't know
but the tape was disgusting and whoever
was responsible had to be punished
Newsome contacted the police hoping
obscenity charges could be pressed
against the creator of the tape once
they were found the tape was taken into
evidence and the low-level police
investigation into the possible culprits
began
while the police officers who viewed the
tape reported nightmares in the weeks
following the creator of the tape was
never found the investigation truly came
to an end when a superior closed the
case and the tape disappeared from the
evidence Locker this as you probably
could have guessed was the work of a
field agent from the SCP Foundation
anistics were then used to erase the
memories of everyone unlucky enough to
witness the tape including Blake Newsome
who could finally rest easy and return
to his filing work the anomalous tape
was now in responsible hands it was
given the designation
scp-1981 and given the object class safe
due to its easily controlled and
self-contained nature proper research
and testing was now able to begin and
while nothing about the construction of
the tape suggested anything inherently
anomalous repeat viewings of the video
made it clear that this went far beyond
mere doctored footage of a presidential
speech every single time the tape is
played both the speech made and the
injuries received by President Reagan
change the few rules the tape seem to
always follow are that Reagan never
reacts to the injuries he's receiving it
always has the same beginning and total
run time and the speech is always
corrupted the speeches have been
described as mostly incoherent lacking
any sort of underlying thematic
structure and largely being composed of
nonsensical anecdotes and parables
so not that dissimilar from a regular
Reagan speech but the topics always turn
incredibly dark and have included
torture mutilation death cannibalism
ritual sacrifice genocide and more
the range of injuries shown on President
Reagan in the videos have included but
are by no means limited to impalement
mutilation and some tortures so gruesome
that the details have been redacted from
official files on several occasions the
details of President Reagan's speech
have also eerily predicted the Future
these include successfully predicting
the September 11th attacks in 2001 and
the outcome of the 2008 Russian
presidential election incidentally this
isn't even the only reagan-related SCP
to predict the future
no there's another entity in this
incredibly specific Niche
scp-095 a highly degraded copy of a
comic known as the atomic Adventures of
Ronnie Ray Gun
the Title Character Bears a striking
resemblance to President Reagan despite
the fact that the comment is confirmed
by Foundation tests to have been written
in the early 1930s the comic is set in
the far-off future world of the 1980s
and follows a number of Ronnie's
exploits in three stories
the first titled Ronnie vs Space Admiral
Carter seems to perfectly describe the
events of the 1980 presidential election
the second space assassin mirrors the
attempted assassination of President
Reagan by John Hinckley Jr
and the third titled jungle Planet
retells the Iran-Contra controversies of
1986. these Comics were produced under
the mysterious and apparently
non-existing company future funnies the
foundation helps to track down the other
comics from this company whenever
possible but they've had no luck on that
front for now there's only
scp-095 during initial testing
Foundation staff watched the tape
frequently in case this strange
corrupted version of President Reagan
had any other valuable predictions for
the future
however during one of these screenings
one of the d-class observation Personnel
pointed and yelled at the screen in
horror upon further examination of
recorded footage researchers could see
exactly what had concerned The d-class
Observer so much
while in other viewings of the tape
President Reagan's press detail had
appeared totally normal and this one
something was clearly amiss standing
among the other doll suit wearing
political AIDS was a tall figure dressed
in a midnight black cloak with a large
conical Hood obscuring his face the
figure didn't appear to move in the
footage it just stood there menacingly a
later survey indicated that this figure
would appear in roughly one in seven
viewings of the tape
this cloaked figure was designated
scp-1981-1 and he became part of the
reoccurring imagery in the nightmares
that often followed a viewing of
scp-1981.
naturally despite containment and
preservation attempts the foundation was
aware that just like any normal tape
natural magnetic interference would
eventually degrade it Beyond use
attempts to copy the footage onto
another betamax tape failed to reproduce
the anomalous effects that's why the
foundation has painstakingly recorded
any video and audio they could via
standard commercial camcorder in one
particularly terrifying playback
scp-1981-1 took the president's place at
the podium staring directly into the
camera the words I see you appeared over
a black screen shortly after staff
members were ordered never to make an
attempt at communicating with the figure
and instead contact a level 4 Superior
if such an event occurs during a
playback again
the frightening and unfortunate effects
of scp-1981 would come to their logical
conclusion under the watchful eye of Dr
James Kyle Robinson managing archivist
of inert safe class objects and
anomalous items at site 73. he was
contacted by special agent Arnold
Rodriguez and special agent Ethan Tate
members of the Secret Service with a
duty to protect President Reagan word
had gotten to Reagan that there was an
anomalous artifact in the possession of
the foundation that directly pertained
to him and he wanted to see it
Dr Robinson obtained files and
transcripts pertaining to scp-1981 and
handed them over to the agents but
refused to allow President Reagan to see
the tape directly without approval from
o5 command but Reagan and the Agents
were persistent eventually o5 command
ordered a private screening of the tape
for President Reagan at the Sanford
chemical processing plan a front
business owned and operated by the
foundation for amnestic production Dr
Robinson offered President Reagan the
use of amnestics after the session
completed but Reagan declined the
screening took place in conference room
B and the tape was replayed three times
it was on the third playback that things
took an interesting turn as the
mutilated Reagan on the screen began to
rant about drinking the blood of a child
from the skull of Vladimir Putin Reagan
began to silently mouth along the words
as though he remembered them he spoke
about beings known as the Destroyers and
potential apocalyptic events to come
after the screening Reagan once again
refused the offer of amnestics and
departed
it seemed as though all was well until a
violent break-in at the Sanford chemical
processing plant that left a night guard
dead
a large number of amnestics had been
stolen during the break-in and security
footage showed that agent Tate and
Rodriguez had been responsible the two
agents were tracked down and traced to
the residents of Ronald Reagan where the
foundation Came Upon a disturbing site
the agents had pillaged large quantities
of Class A and B and me sticks and
supplied them to President Reagan who at
some point after observing scp-1981 had
been driven into a dangerous Madness the
two agents wanted to cure him before he
caused harm to himself or others but
their bungling had come with severe
consequences misapplying such a high
quantity of amnestics had essentially
destroyed Reagan's mind while the
foundation was able to stabilize his
condition his impaired memory and
cognitive function would leave him
unable to care for himself independently
in order to cover up for this Grievous
mistake a cover story was concocted
about Reagan falling victim to
Alzheimer's and facing severe cognitive
decline as a result
both agents tayden Rodriguez were fired
for their actions had their memories
wiped by the foundation and were
assigned new identities Dr Robinson for
his part in the disaster had to face a
foundation Ethics Committee disciplinary
hearing
while scp-1981 continues to be
classified as safe due to its
unlikliness to ever breach containment
when you consider the havoc and rot on
the mind of its singular Target safe is
hardly the word that comes to mind it's
enough to make you wonder what other
tapes are lurking out there just waiting
to be found warning this site is for SCP
personnel with o5 approval access Beyond
this point for those with standard level
4 security is prohibited and may result
in termination of foundation employment
unauthorized visitors who survived the
memet a kill agent are detained and
interrogated under truth exacting the
medic agents
Dr Herman Wright was used to high
security protocols he had been working
with the SCP Foundation for several
years and had dealt with specimens both
terrifying and valuable but something
about this site was different the
security was tighter than he'd ever seen
and it all seemed a bit too much for
what looked like a run-of-the-mill
warehouse in Alexandria Egypt this
street seemed normal it was surrounded
by businesses selling food and clothes
and none of the locals seemed to give a
Second Glance but as soon as he was
approved for Access and entered the
warehouse it was a very different story
he looked into the Cognito Hazard
testing screen designed to cause psychic
damage to anyone who hadn't been
inoculated by the foundation and entered
the large bunker automated guns lined
the walls he could see the outlines of
trap doors below him and he was pretty
sure the whole place was rigged to blow
if a large-scale assault hit the
foundation was taking no chance with
whatever they had found in Egypt what
could they be keeping mocked up alone
has Dr Wright walked through the long
tunnel leading to the staircase he could
see a series of rules marked on the wall
no open Flames allowed with an scp-4001
no firearms or bladed weapons allowed
within
scp-4001 all writing utensils brought
into scp-4001 must be approved by a
majority of the o5 council
violating these conditions could cause a
CK class restructuring scenario or an XK
Class end of the world scenario
Dr Wright's mind raced as he entered the
massive anti-chamber and descended the
staircase but he wasn't prepared for
what he saw it was a library the biggest
library he had ever seen with bookcases
stretched as far as the eye could see
the library was Far bigger than the
warehouse look from the outside and Dr
Wright assumed it must be a disguise
built on top of the much bigger older
facility that had been discovered by the
foundation it wouldn't be the first time
the foundation found something that
didn't conform to the laws of euclidean
geometry SCP locations often played by
their own rules as Dr Wright exited the
staircase and walked up to the first
bookcase
could swear he heard rustling sounds
among the shelves
was something moving he hadn't seen
anyone walking the aisles when he
descended the staircase and he was
pretty sure he was alone here
wasn't he making things stranger a quick
look at the bookcase didn't show any
books he was familiar with none had
standard titles in fact they all seemed
to follow a simple format each title a
different individual person all books
looked the exact same same binding same
thickness same number of pages was this
some sort of SCP Reference Library
suddenly a hand slapped down on Dr
Wright's shoulder and his heart nearly
jumped out of his chest he turned to see
a gray-haired man in an SCP lab coat
extending a hand to him Dr Whalen
Hendricks Chief scientist in charge of
testing at SCP 4001. we all must be Dr
Wright
he didn't give Dr Wright a chance to
respond Dr Hendricks didn't seem like
the kind of man to be very interested in
what others had to say yes yes about
time the foundation sent me a new
research assistant I suppose you have a
lot of questions
Dr Wright was supposed to be a
researcher not an assistant he didn't
suppose it would do any good to point
that out when Dr Wright tried to
question what it was that he'd be
researching Dr henriks told him that it
would be easier to show than explain
with that he motioned Dr Wright to a
nearby table where one of the countless
identical books on the shelves was
waiting he nodded at the book prompting
the younger doctor to turn it over and
read the title he couldn't believe what
he saw there on the front of the book
was his name Herman Wright Dr Wright
looked at his colleague in confusion and
Dr henrik's motion for him to take a
look it was written in a language that
he had never seen before but was somehow
instantly recognizable and
understandable and the book really was
about him every detail of his life had
been written down in this volume
starting with his birth containing
details that no one but he knew his
whole life story was here
from his childhood to his education to
his eventual recruitment by the SCP
Foundation but the book wasn't completed
the last line that had been written
described his entry into the secured
confines of
scp-4001 that very day
Dr henrichs had a mad glint in his eye
are you starting to understand one for
each of us every person who has ever
lived roughly 120 billion people since
the dawn of man their lives all written
down in these books every time someone
is born their book appears in this
library and their story gets written as
it happens the foundation has been
monitoring this site since the 1800s
it's been operating much longer than
that since the dawn of recorded history
Dr Hendrick's past Dr Wright another
book it was simply titled the Hunter and
it chronicled the life of a prehistoric
man who spent his days searching for
Wild game
he lived 23 violent monotonous years
before his story ended abruptly when the
saber-toothed tiger decided it was
interested in the same Mammoth he was
hunting this must have been one of the
oldest books in the library a book for
every person on Earth Dr Wright could
only imagine what the scale of this
massive Library must be Dr Henrik
explained that mapping the library was a
huge challenge before producing a map
from his pocket and laying it out on the
desk
you're at base camp this is where new
births generate on the shelves along
with books pertaining to the first
humans if you want to drag down specific
books you'll need to know where you're
going we've established base camps
around the library to Mark significant
errors in human history with notable
books at each Camp you'll find
generators supplies and beacons to light
your way if you're going back far enough
you could be traveling for days or even
weeks
Dr Wright was fascinated by this bizarre
location containing the sum total of
Human Experience within its massively
expanding walls but there was one thing
he couldn't figure out just why was this
seemingly harmless location featuring
constantly changing books the most
securely guarded SCP he had ever
encountered Dr henricks knew he was
referring to the extensive rules he had
must have seen as he entered the other
doctor reached into his pocket and said
let's just say that around here the pan
is mightier than the sword you press the
pen into Dr Wright's hand and flipped
open the back page of his book
it was blank the rest of his story
waiting to be written what's something
you've always wanted in your life Dr
Rife think literally why not put it in
your book or remove something you've
always wanted gone
slowly Dr Wright thought back to his
teenage years and recalled an injury
that he suffered in a mugging that
damaged his leg and left him with a limp
he nervously used the pen to scribble
out the words and sentences describing
the event
after a few seconds he felt a headache
and suffered from a slight nosebleed
after that the limp and pain from the
injury was gone and he could no longer
recall the event you see Dr Wright
that's the secret of scp-4001
Dr Henrik said with a mad gleam in his
eye this Library doesn't just let us
read the history of humanity it lets us
write it that's why you're here to test
the limit of this power and see what
this Library can do for the foundation
Dr Henrik soon provided Dr Wright with
footage of some of the many tests
conducted in the library and what Dr
Wright saw amazed him the books could
rewrite the laws of nature with alarming
speed as some unfortunate d-class
Personnel found out
d0546 was brought into a room with a
full head of hair the d-class Personnel
was instructed to scribble lost all hair
into his book and he soon started
scratching his head as he rapidly
started shedding hair after less than
two minutes the man was completely bald
d0567 a young woman who had been
brutally injured when attacked by an
escaping SCP was bedridden and would
never walk again according to all the
foundation doctors as the d-class
Personnel used a pen to scribble Over
The Line in her book describing her
injury Dr Wright watch as she suffered a
minor nosebleed and then sat up getting
out of bed as if she had never been
injured and no longer remembered being
attacked Dr Claire Williams a foundation
researcher sick with cancer wrote Into
the book about curing her symptoms and
then addressed the camera explaining
that this was her third time altering
her own book
her lymphoma symptoms had returned after
several months and two years
respectively but it seemed that as long
as she continued to make changes to her
book then she could keep the cancer at
Bay indefinitely
but not all the tests ended with
positive results as Dr Wright moved on
to another selection of tapes labeled
mortality tests a d-class Personnel who
was given a fatal dose of drugs and then
had their death erased from their book
45 minutes later miraculously returned
to life but showed significant cognitive
deficits after another d-class an older
woman killed in a Containment Breach had
her death erased from the book but came
back deeply Disturbed she survived 15
days in containment repeating send me
back let me go over and over again
before committing suicide a d-class
Personnel killed 28 days prior was
brought back by writing returned back to
life in their book but died again just
13 minutes later from a cerebral
hemorrhage
but it was the next tape that was the
most disturbing it documented a new book
that was written by the foundation
depicting the life of a fictional man
down to the slightest detail it was
carefully placed in the correct position
in the archives resembling all the other
books and Dr Wright watched the tape in
amazement as the man resembling the
fictional character created for the book
spontaneously generated in
scp-4001 almost immediately the man
started vomiting blood and died less
than two minutes later the book
carefully described all the things he
died from and stated that this was
exactly as it was supposed to be
fake book then disappeared into the
archives never to be seen again
the archive knew when it was being used
to play with life and death and it
didn't want any part of it the next tape
wasn't a test at all it was a video
interview showing a Greek speaking
scientist speaking with an ancient
looking old man found living in the
archives slowly after its Discovery by
the foundation
the man who described himself as The
Watcher of Alexandria Eternal believed
he was keeping the archive safe from the
Roman Empire and the other Invaders He
was unaware that thousands of years had
passed since his watch began he had been
using the books to write himself another
day of life and to cure his ills ever
since he began guarding the library at
the conclusion of the interview he asked
to leave and this request was granted by
the foundation the ancient man died of
old age shortly after setting foot out
of the library
while the library can't technically cure
death it does seem to have nearly
Limitless ability to prolong life as
long as someone is willing to stay close
by and never forgets to write themselves
another day where did this incredible
power come from an o5 authorized
investigation into the origins of
scp-4001 revealed that under the
archives carpet is a concrete floor
covered by a layer of Ash the ash was
carbon dated to between 70 and 80 000
years old and further analysis revealed
the ash is likely to be the remains of
burnt wood and paper despite there being
no known records within the archive
itself about a major fire having
occurred there Dr Wright didn't have
much time to dwell on the library's
great power of life because he was
suddenly shaken from his thoughts by the
sound of alarms was the library being
breached no it was Foundation officials
led by a man recognized as Dr Lincoln
Abrams the very man who assigned him to
this project and he did not look happy
he explained that he knew what Dr Waylon
henriks had been up to writing in books
changing the lives of subordinates in an
attempt to play God he knew about
everything of course because he had read
Dr henrik's own book
he knew all of the doctor's Secrets he
knew everything no I'm so close Dr
Abrams I know I can crack the archives
rules there's a way to conquer death
here I can feel it
Dr Abrams was done listening and with a
wave of his hand Foundation security
took Dr Hendricks into custody for a
debriefing and likely demotion Dr Abrams
then turned his attention to the new
Young researcher Dr Wright eventful
first day I gather I'll appoint a new
lead scientist shortly but until then
don't disrupt anything remember the
archive is writing our stories as we
speak it's not very happy with Dr
henricks make sure your story turns out
better
and with that Dr Abrams and his security
team departed leaving Dr Herman right
alone with the endless archives of
Alexandria Eternal wondering what would
be written in his own tone as the sound
of new books popping into existence
filled the air with ominous wrestling a
terrified man huddles in the corner
heart pounding in teeth chattering he
sees them coming towards him huge
eight-legged figures Ten Feet Tall at
least with eight black soulless eyes
that seemed to stare hungrily at him
it's like something out of a nightmare
giant man-eating spiders everywhere they
approached the man fangs dripping with
Venom but just as they're about to
strike he vanishes he won't be spider
food today but for this truly unlucky
guy his ordeal is far from over let's
rewind when life gets a little too
boring we all daydream about getting
away maybe you imagine sitting on a
tropical beach or camping in the
mountains and breathing in the fresh air
some of the more adventurous types with
a vivid imagination might daydream about
visiting a parallel universe who
wouldn't want the chance to see what
life is like in another dimension of
course it would only be fun to go there
if he could control where you went and
when you could come back without any
control over it the ability to hop back
and forth between Dimensions would turn
from a blessing to a curse just ask
scp-507
scp-507 unlike most other scps is a
seemingly normal human man he has blonde
hair green eyes and unrecognizable
accent and no other features that might
make him stand out he looks perfectly
average Like a Stranger you'd pass on
the street and never give a second
thought to what sets him apart is not a
physical attribute but rather an ability
that he has yet to develop a firm grasp
on he is is a dimension Hopper with no
control over where he goes or when he'll
get back after appearing on the grounds
of a mental treatment facility with no
identification rambling about a world of
giant spiders
scp-507 was admitted to the hospital and
sedated for his own safety he would
spend several months in treatment for a
variety of supposed disorders but once
he became aware of his surroundings he
attempted to escape the hospital
multiple times during these Escape
attempts he often eluded hospital staff
by mysteriously disappearing and
reappearing in seemingly impossible
places such as behind locked doors or in
rooms blocked off from the rest of the
hospital these disappearances and
reappearances seem to be contrary to
what the hospital staff first believed
Beyond his control the SCP Foundation
became aware of the strange phenomena
surrounding 507 and he was removed from
the hospital and brought to an SCP
Foundation facility once there the
nature of his abilities became much
clearer
scp-507 is able to without intent or
even knowledge that it is about to occur
shift from this reality to another
alternate reality after some time there
with the amount of time varying from
case to case you will shift back to this
reality he has been known to shift
realities while sleeping in the middle
of a sentence and even while bathing or
going to the bathroom the shifts are
unpredictable and there is no telling
what kind of Horrors he will encounter
in the new dimension where he ends up
leading to 507 having seen some very
strange things even by a CP Foundation
standards during one of his shifts 507
found himself in a pitch black room
filled with the sound of muted breathing
using a flashlight he had been given by
the foundation he looked around and
found that he was not alone in the room
with him was a man wearing a black suit
and sunglasses with a frightening
inhumanly wide smile The Smiling man
leaned in towards 507 so close that
their face is nearly touched and said
back so soon terrified 507 fired several
rounds from a foundation-issued pistol
then curled up in the corner of the room
until he shifted back to our reality
this would not be the last time that he
encountered The Smiling man according to
document
507-3b which details all of 507 shifts
into other realities 507 was found in a
Midwestern cornfield by Foundation staff
with brown liquid on his cheek in his
hand he held a human heart with the
words I need you written on it in the
same brown liquid before he shifted back
and landed in the cornfield 507 shifted
to a pitch black room filled with the
sound of muffled crying he turned on his
flashlight taking note of his
surroundings and found himself face to
face with the smiling man once again The
Smiling man had brown liquid leaking
from around its sunglasses which it
wiped onto 507's cheek upon further
examination 507 saw several bullet holes
in The Smiling Man's suit leaking the
same brown liquid he attempted to fire
his pistol like he had the previous time
but it did not fire as The Smiling man
began to approach him 507 turned and ran
he ran for about 10 minutes before
finding a corner where he stayed huddled
once again until he shifted Back The
Smiling man is not the only nightmare
that scp-507 has encountered on his
travels
during another shift 507 described
appearing in a small room filled with
dried corpses a single window and a
flickering light hanging from a ceiling
while attempting to wait out his time in
the room he discovered that the corpses
were capable of movement whenever the
room was in darkness the corpses would
pose themselves like living people when
he looked out the window the corpses
would join him and look out the window
with him when he sat down they would sit
with him in the circle 507 attempted to
pass time by falling asleep but was
unable to do so though many of his
experiences were disturbing only one of
507's documented shifts resulted in him
requesting a memory wipe from the SCP
Foundation on this one he found himself
in the maternity wing of a large
Hospital a creature dressed like a nurse
approached 507 and told him that he was
upsetting the other patients and that it
was time to start the operation 507 was
then wrapped in the straitjacket and
wheeled into an operating room after the
straitjacket was taken off 507 grabbed a
chair and swung it wildly at the
creatures to keep them at Bay until he
shifted back when he asked to describe
the appearance of the nurse creature 507
began screaming in Terror and was unable
to provide a coherent description he
attempted to provide a drawing of the
creature but was only able to produce a
series of jagged lines following this
encounter his request for a memory wipe
was denied other shifts included going
to a world where every surface was
covered with an unidentifiable mold a
land of icy Tundras populated by
aggressive bears and one place that he
refused to describe Beyond repeating the
phrase so many spiders not all of the
worlds that 507 has encountered are
frightening some are simply strange and
unusual during one shift he found
himself on a large basketball court
where six other individuals were playing
a game game of basketball there were two
humans two insectoid creatures one
creature resembling a squid and one
hovering yellow sphere with eight arms
when 507 asked where he was he was
informed that he had arrived at the all
species Sports Center during another
shift 507 found himself in a world made
entirely of gelatin during yet another
shift he appeared in a large Auditorium
filled with 50 000 other dimension
Hoppers who were holding a political
Rally For The People's Dimension Hopper
Republic working with the Republic over
the course of two weeks 507 helped to
overthrow the United States government
and establish a new one run by Dimension
Hoppers
scp-507 was elected representative of
Massachusetts but just before he could
introduce his first official piece of
legislation he shifted back to our
reality one day at the facility a
particularly unusual event involving
scp-507 occurred the events of which
were documented in interview
507-g during a regular check-in it was
discovered that there were somehow two
identical versions of
scp-507 in its room they had apparently
each arrived in the room independently
and have been talking to one another for
about half an hour before being
discovered these two versions were
referred to as 507-a and
507-b when prompted for an explanation
507-b explained that there were more
than one version of scp-507 Afflicted
with uncontrollable Dimension hopping
the doctor inquired as to which one of
the two was the visitor but the two
declined to answer fearing that this
knowledge would cause the foundation to
view one of them as Expendable the two
had multiple shared experiences that
they related to the doctor including
both having encounters with the smiling
man during the interview
507-b disappeared mid-sentence and did
not reappear the doctor asked 0.07-a
about identifiable differences between
his and his Devil's realities
507-a explained that in 507-b's World
President Lincoln was killed by his vice
president whereas in 507-8's world he
was killed by General Lee this
Revelation made it clear that neither
507-a nor 507-b were native to this
reality after this was revealed 507-a
was terminated and examined no
biological reason for 507's ability to
hop from Dimension to Dimension was
found though it was discovered that
several pieces of 507 will shift
Dimensions along with the rest of the
body three days after this interview was
conducted the correct scp-507 reappeared
with no knowledge of his doppelgangers
or what became of them
scp-507 is classified as safe meaning he
doesn't require any real effort to
contain he's also safe in the more
literal sense in that he poses no threat
to anyone else the only person in danger
in the presence of scp-507 is himself as
he has been exposed to many dangerous
conditions during his reality shifts and
it's never known whether 507's next
shift will end up being his last with
the cause of his shift still being
unknown there is nothing that the
foundation can do to prevent them all
they can do is monitor him and provide
him with the items that might ensure his
safety in the future like a handgun
loaded with rubber bullets a tank of air
a high intensity flashlight a week of
ration packs a pair of binoculars a
tracking collar and a camera the
tracking collar allows the foundation to
recover 507 when he shifts back to our
reality in the location other than the
containment facility the rest of the
equipment was granted at his request
based on obstacles that he encountered
in other dimensions due to his docile
nature 507 is given freedom to move
about the facility but when he leaves
his private room an agent must go with
him to document any shifts that might
occur no one is allowed to touch
scp-507 though if it has been more than
two weeks since a shift occurred this
policy stems from an incident in which
an agent who is touching 507 shoulder at
the time of a shift was taken with him
and did not return when he is not
shifting
scp-507 lives a relatively normal life
at the facility he has allowed his own
computer with internet access and can
meet with other safe or euclid-class
scps that are not infectious or
detrimental to his health 507 has
expressed an interest in the unusual and
paranormal and has enjoyed meeting with
other scps including a request to visit
scp-082 for a vacation so far all of
these meetings have occurred without
incident due to his anomalous shifting
scp-507 will never be able to live a
normal life unless he stops shifting he
will likely spend the rest of his days
bouncing between unknown dimensions and
his containment facility just like so
much else about him his relationship to
his special talent is a bit of a paradox
he has the ability to go anywhere to see
things no other person on Earth has ever
seen however because he cannot control
it cannot stop it no matter how far away
he can travel he will never truly be
free at site 19 many anomalies are kept
secure one however does not fit in with
the rest he is a Caucasian man of around
55 years of age who at first glance
seems normal in every way his average
height average weight and dressed in
business attire calling himself Gustav
Noble he seems to be a perfectly
Pleasant American man who seems to be
deeply out of place compared to the
hundreds of other objects and entities
kept at the largest SCP Containment
facility so why is he so closely guarded
What secrets are kept inside this man's
head to understand why
scp-657 is so important one has to go
back to his recovery Mr Noble worked for
years as an Undertaker at a Funeral Home
in the United States not raising any
attention but there was a man who worked
for him and they didn't get along they
argued frequently and one day scp-652
had to correct the man's work something
that he had to do frequently they argued
and suddenly Mr Noble got angry he
yelled out what does it matter you'll be
dead before the end of the week there
were multiple people present and they
all thought Mr Noble must be losing his
mind that is until it came true three
days later the man was working on his
home when he slipped and fell from his
roof he was killed instantly in what
would seem like a tragic accident there
was no evidence pointing to another
cause of death but many people
remembered Mr Noble's Outburst at work
and reported him to the authorities as a
possible killer that was enough for the
police and they arrested Mr Noble they
were never able to find any physical
evidence linking him to the case but
they questioned him relentlessly while
he never indicated that he was
responsible Mr Noble did make similar
comments about one of the arresting
officers also being close to death that
man met his own end two days later when
a suspect fatally shot him during an
apprehension the two deaths seemed
unrelated but the police didn't believe
it and neither did the SCP Foundation
the police were convinced that this
normal looking man had somehow been
involved in the officer's death and they
made a request for federal assistance as
they investigated while they didn't
understand what it happened they knew
they wanted to see the man pay for his
crimes the justice system moved quickly
and Gustav Noble was put on trial for
both murders in near record time he was
convicted of one murder and of
conspiracy to commit the other and he
was sentenced to death according to the
officers who apprehended him he would
soon be facing the death chamber and
Justice would be done but it was all a
lie the SCP Foundation is quite
experienced with extracting prisoners
condemned prisoners are one of their
best sources for the recruiting of
d-class personnel and they know how to
remove a prisoner from incarceration and
leave the authorities no clue that
anything went awry they used those
procedures to retrieve Mr Noble before
his date with the Executioner but unlike
most inmates the foundation plucks from
Death Row this one wasn't headed for
d-class Duty the foundation believed he
was much more important than that they
knew that this man who would soon be
classified as
scp-657 had a unique link to death
itself once secured at site 19
scp-657 was debriefed and investigated
by Foundation officials which is when
they became aware of the full extent of
his abilities
scp-657 had the ability to predict the
time of anyone's death sometimes with
terrifying accuracy all it takes for him
to make a prediction is for him to make
physical contact with the person which
can be something as simple as shaking
their hand the prediction is involuntary
as soon as he makes contact he gets the
information about how much longer they
have to live he was able to predict the
deaths of the two men he had made
contact with down to the day but when
exposed to some d-class Personnel who
had already been slated for termination
the next day he was able to make
predictions down to the minute but there
was one weak spot in
scp-657's prediction
the closer the person he makes contact
with is to their moment of death the
more accurate he is but that works in
Reverse as well if he touches someone
who is still far away from their time of
death his predictions get fuzzier he can
still predict the general time of death
but if it's a decade or more away all he
can see is the year with no more details
no matter how accurate the time he gives
is he never gets any other information
such as the cause of death all he gets
is a number inside his head but while
the details might be unclear they are no
less accurate and every prediction as
cp657 has made about the time of death
has been proven true
scp-657's Powers seem to work the same
on every living person although there
are a few odd exceptions when tested on
a select few SCP agents and doctors he
claimed that his abilities came up empty
he simply couldn't see a time of death
for them and the investigations and
testing proved he was telling the truth
this indicates that future
investigations about these flukes should
Center not on
scp-657 but on the individuals who seem
to be immune so far though no common
link or explanation has been found
between them other than the fact that
they all work for the foundation what
does stay consistent is the reaction
people have to
scp-657 when encountering him people
will nearly always report that they find
him strange unpleasant or creepy they
may be sensing his abilities even if
they're not aware of them but when
they're informed that he can predict the
time of death the unsettling feeling
seems to escalate when they don't know
they simply can't identify what causes
them to have this disturbing feeling
could this be a milder but similar
effect to that caused by scp-053 a small
child who makes otherwise stable people
feel compelled to act violently right
now the reaction people have to scp-657
is not considered a source of concern
but the foundation is keeping an eye on
it
scp-657 is an unusual specimen in other
ways too though and that requires
unusual protocols
scp-657 is one of the lowest security
residents at site 19 with his living
quarters being a large room with a
queen-size bed and any reasonable
amenities he requests he's not
considered a threat to escape and
displays no hostility so the main
concern is keeping him healthy and
stable for future testing his
nutritional needs are taken care of with
the staff providing him with daily meals
and vitamins along with medication for
his arthritis his quarters look closer
to a hotel room than to a cell and
initially he was able to move around
site 19 as he wished as long as he was
accompanied by a staff member of proper
security so why did this have to change
nothing different in scp-657's behavior
and no attempts to escape or security
breaches were made however what did
become clear was that scp-657 freely
wandering around the facility was a
danger not to others but to himself if
he encountered the wrong being this
stems from an experiment where scp-657
was introduced to
scp-076 better known as able and he is
one of the most volatile scps in site
19.
scp-076 consists of two separate
entities a black cube of engraved Stone
and the human-like heavily tattooed male
figure that resides inside it while Abel
spends most of his time dormant in a
death-like state he occasionally awakens
and seeks out the nearest human being
which he then seeks to kill unless he
himself is terminated when killed he
eventually reincarnates within the cube
scp-076 is a puzzle to the foundation
and they thought
scp-657 could help them answer it
scp-657 was introduced to
scp-076-2 as the humanoid able is
officially designated under pretenses of
having him join mobile task force
omega-7 an experimental team consisting
of some powerful but controllable scps
this was really a way to see if scp-657
could answer any questions about
scp-076-2's lifespan given the being
Supernatural nature and unique
Resurrection process it's not a huge
surprise that the answer was no what was
a surprise was how
scp-657 reacted the process of
determining someone's lifespan is
usually quick and easy for scp-657 the
numbers will usually appear in his mind
in just seconds but when he touched
scp-076 6-2 things went very wrong his
eyes immediately rolled back into his
head and he collapsed there was no
physical cause for this but he fell into
a coma and didn't wake up for over a
week after he woke up he was examined
for any lingering health issues and
interviewed so the foundation could
learn what he experienced it turned out
the answer was that he experienced
nothing he had no memory of the events
or of even meeting
scp-076-2 at all this indicates that
either
scp-657's abilities won't work on
anything that's not technically human or
that
scp-076-2 simply doesn't have a lifespan
and will continue to reincarnate forever
it was clear that scp-657 had an
Achilles heel exposure to human-like But
ultimately inhuman scps had the
potential to mess with his abilities and
create serious adverse side effects
while this time he had recovered in only
a
no one knew if the next time would cause
lasting damage it was determined that
security measures needed to be increased
scp-657 would be confined to his
quarters with two security staff members
stationed outside his door at all times
as scp-657 had no unusual or dangerous
physical abilities security is still
minimal compared to other scps and the
foundation has instructed the site to
Grant all reasonable requests for
entertainment and furnishments to ensure
his mental health stays stable but there
is one other thing the foundation is
still trying to avoid the staff has been
ordered to keep their distance from
scp-657 and avoid physical contact
unless absolutely necessary this is
because accidental contact giving
scp-657 access to the death information
could be stressful for both parties the
knowledge of someone's pending death has
been shown to weigh heavy on
scp-657 at as seen in his initial
Outburst against his employee and not
everyone wants to know how much time
they have left minimal physical contact
is the best way to preserve
scp-657s used to the SCP Foundation so
what are the long-term plans for
scp-657 there are still many unanswered
questions about his ability bully has
now been prohibited from interacting
with other non-human scps for his own
safety he could still be used by the
foundation to learn Vital Information
about Foundation agents and the danger
posed to them on upcoming missions one
question is can the death date be
altered with Advanced knowledge for
instance could an agent who is slated to
die in two days on a mission be switched
off that mission to change their death
date or would this create a Time Paradox
potentially upsetting Reality by trying
to change it these and many other
experiments will likely be Tried by the
foundation in the future once a safe
method for testing them is developed and
approved the research continues though
since the best chance the SCP Foundation
has at answering the great mysteries of
death may just rest in the unassuming
older man in sight 19. for more on
another unassuming old man with unique
abilities check out scp-662 Butler's
handbell or watch
scp-053 young girl for more on that
Strange Case